en de pétrole plus ça arrive après le
coc u19
nous avons un secteur hôtelier et
touristique est à genoux en sang et des
impacts de la catastrophe sur
l'environnement marin mais aussi sur les
populations niveau de la santé vont se
faire ressentir pendant des décennies il
faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble pour
deux heures d'émission nous décrypterons
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce jeudi 10 septembre la turquie au
coeur du sommet euro med cède qui se
déroule en ce moment même en corse et
réunit les représentants de sept pays du
sud de l'europe le président français
qui doit s'exprimer dans quelques
instants appelé avant ce sommet à faire
front commun face aux ambitions d'ankara
en méditerranée les européens doivent
selon lui être clair et ferme avec le
gouvernement du président r doan des
déclarations jugée arrogante ou par la
turquie
face à la résurgence du commis dans
france emmanuel macron promet des
mesures déclinées territorialement mais
sans céder à la panique que quoi que ce
soit une déclaration du président la
veille du conseil de défense
le maire de nice christian estrosi
annonce lui que les visites dans les
ehpad municipaux vont être suspendus
septième jour du procès des attentats de
janvier 2015 la cour d'assises spéciale
du tribunal de paris entend les proches
des victimes de la tuerie perpétrée dans
les rédactions de charlie hebdo
cinq ans après la tragédie la
publication des caricatures de charlie
hebdo où on est et la liberté
d'expression en france charlie tout ça
pour ça ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
le ferroviaire au coeur du plan de
relance du gouvernement près 2,5
milliards d'euros iront à la sncf le
train fait son grand retour à la faveur
de la transition énergétique mais les
défis à venir sont nombreux pour
l'entreprise publique
ouverture à la concurrence gestion de
l'après qu'ovide au final sncf est elle
vraiment la grande gagnante de ce plan
on obtient tel qu'un répit une question
à laquelle tentera de répondre notre
économiste jacques sapir
[Musique]
les tensions en méditerranée orientale
au coeur du sommet du médecin qui se
déroule en ce moment en corse ajaccio
accueille depuis cet après midi cette
alliance informelle qui réunit sept pays
méditerranéens membres de l'union
européenne
une rencontre présidée par emmanuel
macron le chef de l'état français a
appelé avant ce sommet l'europe à plus
d'unité de clarté face à la turquie qui
il dit ne plus considérer comme un
partenaire ankara de son côté l'accusent
de mettre en péril les intérêts de
l'europe t au combat avec valentin
carpentier un sommet brûlant sous le
soleil corse
emmanuel macron accueille à partir de ce
jeudi
le médecin est ce forum informel composé
de sept pays a été lancée en 2016 dans
un contexte de fracture entre les états
du nord de l'europe et ceux du sud sur
fond de crise économique grecque
un groupe qui se réunit pour la première
fois en france dans un climat de tension
en méditerranée orientale
objectif que les pays de cette alliance
également membre de l'union européenne
fasse front commun avant la prochaine
réunion des 27 sur la question mais nous
devons nous européens être clair et
ferme avec non pas la turquie comme
nation comme peuple mais avec le
gouvernement du président erdogan qui
aujourd'hui à des comportements
inadmissibles et j'en ai cité qu'une
partie la turquie de son côté a voulu
répondre en pointant du doigt
l'arrogance du président français le
président français macron a encore une
fois fait des déclarations arrogantes
dans un vieux réflexe colonialiste
le chef d'état français favorise les
tensions et mettent en péril les
intérêts de l'europe et de l'union
européenne
depuis plusieurs semaines la question de
la recherche et de la propriété des
gisements d'hydrocarbures provoque une
véritable escalade des saillies verbales
et des démonstrations de force entre la
république hellénique et chypre d'un
côté et la turquie de l'autre athènes et
nicosie dénonce les prospections turque
dans des eaux que les deux capitales
estiment relever de leur souveraineté
des accusations jugées comme nulle et
non avenue par ankara
notre pays comme vous le savez outre
l'agression fait face à des actions de
la turquie qu'il conteste toutes les
règles de la charte des nations unies la
turquie porte une rhétorique qui
déforment l'histoire échange la
géographie sapant la légalité les
actions qui mettent en danger la
sécurité dans toute la méditerranée
[Musique]
ce n'est pas sincère
les pays de l'union européenne sont
lassés par la grèce car elle tient en
otage des relations turquie union
européenne tout le monde dit que la
grèce a tort du point de vue du droit
international
un dossier majeur pour emmanuel macron
particulièrement impliqué depuis le
début dans cette crise le président
français a affirmé au cours des
dernières semaines son soutien ses
homologue chypriote et grecque
déployant même plusieurs bâtiments de
guerre dans la zone concernée
la réunion du med 7 ne devrait durer que
quelques heures mais pourrait permettre
de rassurer athènes et nicosie
quant au soutien des pays méditerranéens
membres de l'union européenne
mais pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir à claude
blanchemaison on attend la locution
d'emmanuel mac ont capturé un petit peu
de retard depuis les camps ce mais ya
quand même eu des déclarations avant
donc à la tenue de ce sommet dont une
conviendra la turquie met plus un
partenaire a dit le président français
est ce qu'on est
claude blanchemaison un tournant le
torchon brûle officiellement entre les
deux pays je crois que dans les
déclarations qui ont été faites avant le
début de la conférence et dans les échos
qu'on en a il faut retenir la tribune
que le premier ministre grec a publié
cet après-midi dans le journal le
monde une tribune assez équilibrée au
bout du compte dans lequel dans laquelle
monsieur vie de cet atys effectivement
indique que la situation est grave que
les propos belliqueux de monsieur arts
de vannes qui dure depuis maintenant un
certain temps sont inacceptables que ces
propos sont tenus à l'écart de la grèce
et à l'égard de shit mais aussi à
l'égard de l'union européenne dans son
ensemble est d'ailleurs l'union
européenne se solidarise avec ses états
membres que sont la grèce et et chypre
alors monsieur vitre est acquise dans
dans cette tribune et je pense qu'il a
repris cette démonstration tout à
l'heure cet après midi qui est encore en
train de la développer
indique que dans le fond si la turquie
veut éviter l'imposition de nouvelles
sanctions
lors du conseil européen du 24 et du 25
septembre prochain
eh bien il faut qu'elle arrête ses
explorations pétrolières dans la zone
contestée zone qui se trouve entre l'île
de crète qui est fait partie de la grèce
et chypre qui est un état donc
indépendant et zone contestée par
conséquent que la grèce considère comme
faisant partie de ses eaux territoriales
donc il faut que le navire qui fait
actuellement de l'exploration pétrolière
dans cette zone
en fait des explosions pour voir quelle
est la résonance et s'il ya des poches
hydrocarbures se retire de cette zone
et puis que monsieur erdogan cesse de
proférer des propos belliqueux à tout
propos et à tout moment
d'ailleurs il est assez isolée monsieur
erdogan parce qu'à part l'accord qu'il a
conclu avec le gouvernement de tripoli
et il n'a pas beaucoup d'amis qui le
soutiennent ouvertement dans cette
affaire il est un peu seul sur la scène
internationale donc actuellement chacun
se jauge et je pense que dans les quinze
jours qui nous séparent du conseil
européen
il faut encore ménagé les une voie de
sortie au premier ministre turc
mais évidemment pour cela il faut qu'il
cesse son agression et qu'il cesse son
comportement belliqueux
alors on le disait quand même la turquie
n'est plus un partenaire a dit le
président français de son côté en quarts
a dit
que ces propos sont inacceptables
emmanuel macron mettant en péril
l'europe on a quand même l'impression
que la blanche maison d'un dialogue
rompu qui va être difficile à restaurer
dire que monsieur erdogan a toujours
l'habitude de tenir des propos excessifs
il a traité emmanuel macron et les
français de néocolonialistes parce
qu'ils étaient allés aider les libanais
ceci évidemment incomplètement est
complètement tirée à l'ifth à face à na
aucun sens et je pense qu'il reviendra à
la raison
d'ailleurs en turquie un certain nombre
d'éléments est compris dans l'armée
turque considère que les propos et
l'attitude du président sont un peu
aventuriste ce n'est peut-être pas le
meilleur moyen d'obtenir gain de cause
puisque le fond de la question c'est
qu'un jour il faudra bien s'asseoir à la
table avec les grecs pour déterminer les
limites des eaux territoriales de la
limite des vins et des autres et puis
comme l'a dit aussi le premier ministre
grec cet après midi et bien si cette
négociation échoue ou si elle n'a pas
lieu parce que monsieur erdogan ne s'y
prête pas et bien la grèce se portera
d'affaires devant la cour de justice
internationale de la haye et la cour
tranchera
il ya un droit de la mer il ya une
convention sur le droit de la mer par
conséquent les juges internationaux sont
parfaitement en l'état de trancher ce
différend
alors on attendait on le disait un
électron son allocution en tout cas pour
19h30
il ya du retard 1 40 minutes ça laisse
présager à des négociations difficiles
selon vous à quoi doit-on s'attendre à
l'issue de ce sommet à cette satanée pas
un conseil de guerre dirigée contre
contre la turquie
c'est une réunion diplomatique
évidemment chacun exprime ses positions
l'objectif est le même c'est de faire en
sorte que monsieur erdogan rentrer dans
le droit chemin et et qu'il respecte
l'état de droit international et qu'il
cesse ses propos belliqueux à tout
moment et pour cela évidemment il ya
plusieurs méthodes
ah les sanctions et puis il ya le
dialogue est probablement que cet après
midi l'italie et l'espagne ont indiqué
que je ne fallait pas rompre les canaux
du dialogue et qu'il fallait renforcer
sans doute la position de l'union
européenne et de la grèce et de chypre
mais aussi probablement proposé un
dialogue avec monsieur à dogan est en
effet lui montrer le chemin du d'un
retour à une situation normale
alors il le suivra le suivre à part et à
ce moment là il faudra en effet à
réévaluer la situation
l'union européenne a deux semaines avant
le conseil européen ces deux semaines
vont certainement être cruciales pour
l'avenir pour l'avenir des relations
avec la turquie alors ses relations
comme vous le savez sont des relations
qui sont assez fortes puisque la turquie
est le cinquième client de l'union
européenne sur le plan commercial
la turquie est dans une situation d'
union douanière avec avec l'union
européenne et la turquie bénéficie d'une
aide préadhésion puisque même si on a
parle plus beaucoup
la perspective plus ou moins lointaines
étaient que la turquie pourrait un jour
adhérer à l'union européenne ses astuces
fictive est en train de s'estomper
mais l'aide de préadhésion demeure et
une tranche de cette aide prévision a
été suspendue l'année dernière
puisqu'ils avaient déjà eu une première
sanction
on pourrait imaginer en effet si les
choses tournaient mal qu'une autre
partie de cette aide a des yeux près
adhésion soit suspendu on verra au
niveau du conseil européen
quelle sera la position allemande moi je
ne doute pas que ce soir ou demain matin
monsieur mâcon rendra compte des débats
de cet après-midi 17 pays méditerranéens
et sept pays du sud de l'union
européenne d'une part à charles michel
le président du conseil européen et
d'autre part à angela merkel qui puisque
le fait l'allemagne qui ont actuellement
exerce la présidence de l'union
européenne et le rendra compte en sans
doute leur indiquant à son avis quelles
sont les possibilités d'avancer dans
quel est dans quelle voie le conseil
européen pourra se diriger dans deux
semaines merci
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales et en attendant que
cette allocution d'emmanuel micro on
viendra évidemment sur sa déclaration si
elle a lieu entre temps dans notre
édition de 21h merci à vous il est aussi
question de la politique migratoire de
l'union européenne après l incendie qui
a dévasté le camp de réfugiés de moria
sur l'île de lesbos en grèce le plus
grand camp de réfugiés du pays hébergées
quelques près de 13000 demandeurs
d'asile dont 4000 enfants c'est 4 fois
sa capacité d'accueil
la commission européenne a annoncé
qu'elle prenait en charge le transfert
immédiat vers la grèce continentale de
400 enfants et adolescents de son côté
la chancelière allemande confirme ce
soir une autre initiative de paris et
berlin cette fois 400 autres migrants
mineurs non accompagnés seront répartis
entre les pays lieu qui se rallieront à
cette démarche en attendant la situation
humanitaire est catastrophique sur place
écouter ces quelques réactions mais nous
avons 300 familles et je veux dire au
moins 300 familles qui dorment dans la
rue n'ont pas de nourriture n'ont rien à
l'est à l'intérieur de moria si vous
trouver de l'eau vous buvez si vous ne
trouvez pas vous restez assoiffés
vous restez affamés cette situation est
tragique tout le corps à brûler zone
neuf jaunes six toutes les tentes
[Musique]
maintenant nous n'avons plus de
nourriture plus de temps nous dormons
sur la route c'est très très dur
le président libanais estiment que l'
incendie qui s'est déclaré à beyrouth
pourrait venir d'un sabotage selon ses
mots michel aoun lui envisage également
une erreur technique ou une église en
urgence qui pourrait être à l'origine de
l'incident
un nouveau sinistre quelques semaines
après l'explosion qui a dévasté une
partie de la capitale libanaise
vincent dit
a pris dans un entrepôt où la
croix-rouge entrepose de l'aide
alimentaire selon l'organisation
elle fait état d'un blessé par
suffocation la défense civile et l'armée
se sont déployés sur place en direct de
béraut tout à leur foi de ce mot cole
président du rassemblement des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise
libanais ait une panique générale dans
le pays on entend des ambulances on
entend des pompiers qui vont mais
toujours des pompiers qui ont très peur
à savoir que la plupart des pompiers
pour ne pas dire tous les pompiers qui
sont allés il ya un mois pour essayer
d'éteindre l'incendié du port sont
partis en morceaux malheureusement on ne
trouve même plus le reste donc il ya
aussi une peur que dramatique
l'armée a fermé certaines routes pour
empêcher de passants ou de certains
curieux de venir mais je vous ne vous
cache pas qu'il ya beaucoup de panique
mais en même temps on est très dérangé
de ce qui se passe parce que une fois de
plus ça prouve la mauvaise gestion la
mauvaise gouvernance la mauvaise
transparence qui se passe c'est vraiment
dramatique qu à ce niveau une fois de
plus après un mois d'une explosion qui
la troisième plus grande explosion du
monde
on a un incendie quai au même moment bon
d'un côté on sait que c'est on a su que
c'est beaucoup plus des pneus ou de
l'huile qui a qui a pris feu mais vous
je ne vous cache pas que si c'est une
incident criminel pour cacher certaines
preuves c'est dramatique
et si c'est un incident par accident
c'est encore pire c'est à dire que
jusqu'à cet instant
nos forces ne sont pas à pouvoir au même
protégé quand même les pouvoirs publics
la situation sanitaire en france présent
et les derniers chiffres plutôt
inquiétants 9840 trois nouveaux cas de
co vite confirmée par un test
le pays compte 350 de nouvelles
hospitalisations liées au virus en 24
heures
il s'agit du total 2
nouveau call le plus élevé depuis le
début des tests à grande échelle et pour
en parler nous sommes avec violaine
guérin médecin endocrinologue membre du
collectif laissons les médecins à
prescrire bonsoir violaine guérin merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
tout d'abord une première réaction sur
ces chiffres
vous êtes inquiète comment vous
définiriez la situation aujourd'hui
bonsoir et merci de m'accueillir je
donnais des problèmes de connexion on ne
peut pas que le voir deux fois
je dois aussi vous dire tout de suite
que je n'ai aucun conflit d'intérêts
quand je prends la parole pour répondre
à votre question nous sommes en train de
tester à tout va sans indication
clinique il ya un court-circuitage total
des médecins généralistes qui fait que
la population qui est extrêmement pressé
par les annonces hyper at il se
précipite dans les laboratoires et nous
avons aujourd'hui un nombre de textes
complètement démesuré par rapport à la
réalité de la situation et un nombre de
textes qu'on aurait bien aimé avoir au
mois de mars au mois d'avril on a des
tests qui ne sont pas toujours fiables
puisque vous avez plein doute entendu je
pense qu'ils expliquaient que quand il
essayait de 50 des actions avec des
tests positifs voulait confirmer cette
positivité en fonction de l'origine des
tests il y avait entre 25 et 40% de
tests faux positifs donc ça déjà c'est
un premier élément
et deuxièmement quand vous vous
présentez même votre introduction il
faut faire attention de faire la
différence entre avoir un test positif
et avoir la maladie parce qu' énormément
de gens sont atteints automatique et
donc on ne peut pas vraiment dire que ce
sont des cas pathologiques en fait ça
c'est important parce que si on avait
fait des tests au moins de marché au
mois d'avril on aurait eu probablement
plus de cent mille tests positifs à
cette époque-là par jour donc
aujourd'hui le
nombre de têtes n'est pas inquiétant
mais on fait extrêmement peur c'est pas
rassurant violaine guérin ce que vous
nous dites parce qu'on nous annonce
quand même des chiffres importants vous
nous expliquer effectivement que cette
stratégie de dépistage ne fonctionne pas
on s'en est d'ailleurs peut-être tous
rendus compte si on a eu à faire des
tests aujourd'hui clairement comment on
s'en sort bien écoutez il faut que la
population comprenne que elle doit
passer par faim médecins généralistes
qui décidera si c'est opportun ou pas de
faire les tests parce qu'aujourd'hui en
plus ça nous empêche complètement de
travailler sur le terrain puisque les
laboratoires sont complètement emboliser
moi j'ai passé ma semaine là à voir des
patients qui viennent pour des
pathologies compact lui faire leur
examen biologique
parce que il n'ya 3 4 heures de queue
sur sur des laboratoires donc c'est très
important
ne vous faites pas testé sans avoir un
avis médical ça n'a aucun sens de toute
façon de faire un test en étant
totalement atteint automatique ou pour
voir si parce que de toute façon pour
voir si et bien 48 heures après on peut
très bien avoir à être en contact avec
quelqu'un donc c'est faut faire des
textes de façon avec des indications
cliniques tout à fait pertinente
donc aujourd'hui également sur le
terrain les médecins généralistes ou les
médecins spécialistes comme moi on ne
voit pas de cas graves de co vide et la
plupart des personnes d'ailleurs n'ont
même pas vu de copie de patient malade
depuis plusieurs mois donc il faut se
méfier parce que on peut avoir un impact
positif aussi et avoir tout à fait autre
chose au niveau symptomatique
il y à une telle terreur que les gens
des symptômes de stress qui ne
correspond pas du tout à la maladie il y
a des gens qui sont déprimés qu'ils ont
des complications du port du masque tout
à fait
enfin petits peuvent même être graves
moi j'ai dû bondé d'acné ça fait cinq
six états programme une tapis des hawks
fille de la fac ça c'est beaucoup plus
grave
cette semaine j'ai vu une femme enceinte
un hypocrite parce que ce n'était pas du
tout opportun pour elle de porter un mac
alors qu'il n'y a aucune justification
médicale
donc on est dans quelque chose de tout à
fait irrationnel et notre rôle je pense
est médecin et de rassurer les patients
et de l'or vraiment de les conseiller de
contacter leur médecin
celui qui les connaît keller référent
ils ont des questions lors qu'ils ont
des symptômes et qu'il soit examiné
ausculté et qui parlent pas ne pas faire
des bilans biologiques comme fable façon
tout à fait irrationnel violencia
dernière question demain conseil de
défense emmanuel macron on nous promet
des annonces il nous parle notamment de
territorialité à quoi vous vous attendez
ce qu'on doit crainte de nouveau
confinement notamment et bien écoutez
sur le plan sanitaire il n'y a aucune
justification à plat d'abord parce que
je rappelle qu'il ya des traitements
disponibles impact très coffre fait
quelque chose qu'on ne veut pas entendre
en france mais il ya énormément de
publication et vous savez prévenir aussi
que le collectif laissons les médecins à
prescrire à traiter quand c'était
accessible
les médecins nous nous sommes prêtés
avec le protocole et roxy clan qui m'a
dit ronnie signer on a une publication
internationale sur le sujet donc il y
avait les traitements phase précoce qui
ne justifiait aucunement toutes les
mesures là tout à fait liberticide donc
on n'est plus dans un problème de de
santé publique on est dans un problème
politique
donc on est extrêmement inquiète de ce
qui se passe on souhaite que le conseil
scientifique que toutes les personnes
qui ont des conflits d'intérêts et je
peux vous dire que la liste est
extrêmement longue dans le concept
scientifique sorte ce concept
scientifique
si on veut vraiment faire de la santé
publique pas de la politique
donc aujourd'hui côté tout est possible
dans les annonces de main il ya des
choses tout à fait irrationnel et bon
ben on va attendre demain mais en tout
cas par rapport à vos auditeurs qui sont
des patients potentiels ou quand des
personnes âgées autour d'elle ou des
enfants
voilà on veut vous ratures et ça c'est
très important
vous avez entendu que le il ya beaucoup
de mythes actions de ce virus qui va
nettement moins pathogène a nettement
moins palliatifs
donc s'il ya des doutes il ya des
questions consulter vos médecins
généralistes qu'ils examinent qui
prescrivent les les examens
complémentaires qui sont nécessaires et
je rappelle à mes confrères dont
beaucoup aussi son horreur peur parce
que il ya des menaces des conseils de
l'ordre yade et on a des mails tous les
jours la direction générale de la santé
fait vraiment de la clinique vous avez
traité une grippe vous avez prêté une
pneumonie
appliquez de la médecine vraiment qu'une
hygiène et et et voiliers confiance dans
vos capacité d'accompagner les passions
comme on le fait d'habitude
merci viennent vers un médecin des
membres du collectif laissons les
médecins prescrivent est toujours
concernant la crise sanitaire les trois
médecins du collectif c 19 qui avait
porté plainte contre olivier vers ans
agnès buzyn edouard philippe pour
dénoncer leur gestion de l'épidémie ont
été entendus hier matin par la cour de
justice de la république
ces auditions sont les premières depuis
le déferlement de procédures mi mars sur
les 90 plaintes déposées neuf dont ce
dossier ont finalement été retenus
fabrice di vizio avocats des trois
praticiens se félicite de cette audition
la vérité c'est un mot compliqué dans
cette affaire parce que en permanence
vous avez eu à faire et c'est une
constante à des gens qui vous ont menti
sur toute la durée de l'épidémie ce plus
particulièrement dans sa phase aiguë et
donc les miens mes clients c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles ils ont déposé
plainte parce qu'à un moment donné il y
avait une déclaration officielle est ce
que je vivais sur le terrain et pour le
coup hier nous avons trois magistrats
trois hauts magistrats quand même dont
on pourrait se dire qu'il avait mieux à
faire qui les ont entendus qui les ont
écoutés et qui donc sont désireux de
cette recherche de la vérité du terrain
il serait peut être temps maintenant de
considérer que le temps de
l'irresponsabilité est terminée
et qu'ils auront à répondre de la
gestion de cette crise et que ce n'est
certainement pas un an faisant trou ou
en faisant effectivement n'importe quoi
comme ils sont en train de le faire en
ce moment que ils vont échapper à leur
responsabilité que j'ai des crises
sanitaires ça demande une transparence
et sa demande effectivement une
adéquation entre des mesures sanitaires
et les libertés individuelles
cette demande de s'appuyer sur le réseau
sanitaire est manifestement le problème
c'est qu'il n'en prend pas le chemin le
gouvernement reste avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
liberté d'expression france alors que se
tient le procès des attentats de 2005 et
du journal satirique charlie hebdo qui a
re publié les caricatures de mahomet
puis on se rend avec l'économiste
jacques sapir qui nous parlera de la
sncf va t'elle vraiment profiter du plan
de relance
[Musique]
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire la france allait
voir c'est ainsi que de polichinelle je
ne crois pas qu'il appartient à la
france des données problème entre
ivoiriens
le bénin ouattara et son régime sont en
train d'imprimer leurs prêts plus il
faut demander au régime ivoiris
différents sortes d n'est pas crisper
davantage les positions la tension est
déjà trop lourd vous demandé un report
des scrutins prévus le 31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
dans les circonstances pareilles c'est
le conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
oh
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez où on
est la liberté d'expression en france en
plein procès des attentats du 7 janvier
2015 après la rue publication des
caricatures de charlie hebdo les
chiffres semblent plutôt alarmant
florian lambert le combat d'une vie
c'est en ces termes que l'équipe de
charlie hebdo évoque la liberté
d'expression cinq ans après la tuerie du
7 janvier 2015 qui a décimé la rédaction
du journal est choqué la france entière
charlie choisi de republier les
caricatures du prophète mahomet publiées
pour la première fois en 2006 est à
l'origine de la tacc djihadistes des
frères kwasi un choix courageux pour
certains provocateur pour d'autres cinq
ans après quel est l'état de la liberté
d'expression en france
le 2 septembre dernier charlie hebdo
publie une enquête de l'ifop sur l'état
de l'opinion en matière de liberté
d'expression de blasphème et de
caricature dans ce sondage
59% des sondés considèrent que le
journal a eu raison de publier ces
caricatures au nom de la liberté
d'expression
un chiffre en hausse de 21 points par
rapport à 2006 lors de la première
publication des dessins par charlie
hebdo
moi je sens qu'il faut pas se coucher je
crois que l'esprit de la france c'est ce
à quoi faut pas se coucher c'est vrai
que c'est une tragédie ce qui t'arrive à
charlie mais il faut pas céder quoi l'on
sait pas si ça ne doit jamais mourir en
fait faut pas oublier en fait on n'a pas
le droit en fait c'est important qu'ils
tiennent cette position après c'est
courageux de leur part quoi
j'aimerais bien d'autres éditeurs
puissent prendre le relais tête parfois
ils recueillirent publie chez continuer
à acheter votre problème pour les
avocats et proche de charlie hebdo l'art
publication des caricatures s'inscrit
dans le combat de la liberté
d'expression pour les futures
générations
ils se battent et continue à se battre
malgré les menaces malgré le fait qu'ils
n'ont plus de vie qui peuvent plus se
balader avec leurs femmes dans la rue
qui les vivent en résidence surveillée
qu'ils ont été obligés d'abandonner
leurs vies personnelles qu'ils vivent
dans un bunker qui continuent à se
battre
ils ont ce courage là de les republier
il est république pour les autres pour
ces jeunes générations là pour que
puisse continuer à vivre libres même
s'ils ne comprennent pas l'importance de
de la possibilité de garder son esprit
critique y compris à l'égard des
religions mais c'est plus large que les
religions c'est de toute idéologie à la
veille de l'ouverture du procès des
attentats de janvier 2015
emmanuel macron avait défendu depuis le
liban la liberté de blasphémer
je pense qu'un président de la
république en france n'a jamais a
qualifié le choix éditorial d'un
journaliste ou d'une rédaction jamais
parce que la liberté de la presse à
laquelle vous tenez à juste titre
profondément il ya aussi en france une
liberté de blasphémer en france on peut
critiquer des gouvernants un président
blasphémer etc
l'enquète de l'ifop affirme néanmoins
que chez les moins de 25 ans 47% d'entre
eux ne sont pas en accord avec la ligne
éditoriale du journal
autre chiffre marquant 21 % des jeunes
français ne condamne pas explicitement
les auteurs des attentats
des chiffres éloquents qui n'ont pas
tardé à faire réagir l'ancien premier
ministre manuel valls qui se livrent à
une explication politique
quand je vois qu'il y à 20 % de jeunes
qui disent ne pas à condamner les
auteurs de ces attentats
le travail de fond et de pédagogie n'a
pas été suffisamment fait la liberté
d'expression a reculé parce qu'une
partie de la classe politique
une partie de la gauche a reculé d'après
un classement de reporters sans
frontières sur la liberté de la presse
la france se classe seulement en 34e
position en 2020 ces deux places de
perdues en un an pour le pays des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen et cinq ans
après la tête de charlie hebdo les
journalistes survivante cette attaque
ont dénoncé je cite ceux qui ont préparé
le terrain à l'attentât de 2015
dans leur collimateur intellectuels et
journalistes qui contestent le danger de
l'islam politique et la liberté
d'expression depuis quelques jours on
voit d'ailleurs les acteurs de ce procès
historique être parfois entre guillemets
censuré par les réseaux sociaux d'où le
titre de notre débat charlie tout ça
pour ça la censure est elle plus que
jamais d'actualité
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
gamal à bina cofondateur du mouvement
des droits civiques bonsoir à gamma
nabina merci d'être avec nous à ses
côtés jean mais si y'a membre du bureau
national du rnb soir avoue aussi j'en
mets ça merci d'être à tous les deux
d'avoir c'est d'être avec nous on dirait
que certes et français d'avoir accepté
ce débat alors avant de vous donner la
parole je propose de regarder celui de
coco qui date de dimanche dernier cette
dessinatrice de charlie avec dow écoeuré
par la suppression de son compte
instagram pour y avoir publié la une de
son magazine comme ma concert de charlie
hebdo
lord aussi mon compte instagram a été
désactivé suite à la diffusion de la
couverture tout ça pour ça avec les
caricatures de mahomet tout simplement
scandaleux car entre 100 et 120 que
compte le comté été réactivé mais il a
été bel et bien supprimer un bon moment
tout ça pour ça dit-elle que vous
inspire ce tweet de coco est ce que vous
comprenez cette suppression gamme
alabina oui c'est évident le mans reste
à g n'est pas débat de société française
étaient américains c'est des anglo
saxons qui ont un rapport au religieux
qui est extrêmement mesure et on n'est
pas du tout dans la liberté absolue on
n'est pas dans le pays du marquis de
sade on n'est pas dans le pays de l'idée
du blasphème quasiment keynésien parce
qu un principe de vie non les anglo
saxons font très attention de ne pas
flirter leurs minorités c'est normal on
ne peut plus rien dire écrire ou
montrait sous peine d'être censuré jean
messia bah écoutez moi je ne partage pas
l'analyse de mon contradicteur parce que
en réalité ce qui s'est passé sur
instagram pour ces deux journalistes
c'est tout simplement le résultat de
signalements massif c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas quelqu'un derrière chaque
compte pour le verrouiller à moins que
ces comptes soient massivement signaler
ce qui semble être le cas en tout cas
c'est ce que le réseau instagram a
souligné donc on peut pas d'un côté dire
qu' il n'y a pas de menace islamiste que
tout ça est un fantasme qu'il n'y a pas
de guerre identitaire en
ça et en même temps je dirais ne pas
reconnaître que la masse de signalement
a été suffisante pour suspendre ces deux
ces deux comptes
j'ajoute que bien sûr qu'on peut dire on
doit pouvoir tout dire moi j'entendais
dans votre reportage les mots combat et
se battre mais le combat de la liberté
d'expression il s'effectue contre qui il
s'effectue bien entendu contre une
sécession identitaire islamistes en
l'occurrence qui émane de certaines
immigrations qui entendent appliquer en
france eu une culture des lois qui ne
sont tout simplement pas les nôtres la
france est connue pour ses pamphlets
parfois très brute est très violent du
temps de louis xiv
c'est une véritable tradition de
caricatures tant qu'on ne s'attaque pas
à des individus mais on s'attaque à des
messages religieux et bien la loi permet
le de critiquer la religion moi je ne
dis pas que je partage le point de vue
de charlie attention un jeu je suis
quelqu'un de chrétiens je comprends
qu'on peut être choquées par les
caricatures de charlie mais je vais dire
que là encore c'est une contradiction
moi quand je vais dans la rue au même
titre que des milliers des millions de
français je suis choqué de voir des gens
habillés en voile en djellaba etc qui
constitue une sorte de provocation à
notre civilisation c'est pas pour ça que
j'irai que j'irai les tuer vous
comprenez on peut être choqué par
quelque chose on peut trouver ça de
mauvais goût mais évidemment que la
liberté d'expression doit pouvoir être
le cadre général où tout le monde
s'exprimer ici les gens sont pas
contents eh bien ils ont qu'a porté
plainte
ils ont qu'à critiquer ouvertement mais
en aucune façon
arrivé à ces intimidations et à ces
meurtres a alors ce qui est montré du
doigt par les parties civiles au procès
charlie c'est clairement la montée d'un
islam politique auquel vous faites
référence qui mettaient en danger selon
eux la liberté d'expression je vous
propose d'écouter la journaliste zineb
el rhazoui
une des rescapées de charlie suivi du
tweet de son avocat thibault de
montbrial quel était le mobile du crime
sissonnais l'idéologie cette idéologie
on en est où par rapport à ça en france
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on exerce notre
liberté d'expression en france
est ce qu'il ya un journal qui oserait
publier quelque chose qui fâche ray les
islamistes c'est légal de le faire mais
faites le à vos risques et périls
en tout cas moi je prends le risque tous
les jours de dénoncer ça parce que
c'était ça qu'on faisait à charlie et le
sang qui a coulé il a coulé pour cette
cause là et cette cause là il faut
continuer à la défendre
pour ceux qui lisent on les compte
rendus d'audience où certains fil
twitter de procès charlie et charlie
hebdo n'en auraient pas conscience les
parties civiles entendu ont toutes
dénoncé le totalitarisme islamiste
la réticence de certains à leur apporter
en dit long c'est une attaque en règle
vous partagez cette forme d'autocensure
des journalistes on ne voudrait pas
faire de vagues on on nommerait pas les
choses gamme hanna mina absolument pas
c'est un mensonge alors le problème
c'est que quand il ya un drame
s'ils s'étaient passés chez renault
finalement ça crée une émotion qui est
lourde et ça donne le sentiment que ou
souto sangsues mais c'est absolument pas
vrai il suffit de voir la liberté tout
en parlant du carreyrat celle qui t'a
juin que j'aime beaucoup qui lui
autorise régulièrement effectivement à
rêver tedesco la d'état qui n'hésitait
pas à utiliser un personnage que
j'aimais beaucoup si tu as vu comme
dessinateur je rappelle que je suis
dessinateur aussi que je fais beaucoup
de caricatures et que j'ai pas de
problème avec ça en revanche il ya
liberté d'expression et il y a la
liberté de provocation jusqu'à la
liberté d'injures et le problème du
charlie hebdo pour moi j'aime beaucoup
de canard parce que c'est un journal qui
est sain qui me fait rire les dessins
sont très à-propos charlie hebdo ne fait
pas du tout rire depuis début d'ailleurs
depuis la terre en soixante dix avec
hara-kiri quand ils ont ils ont ils ont
bloqué le général de gaulle parce qu'il
a fait de se faire tuer
ça donne une petite idée de l'heure le
rapport au respect j'allais dire que un
journal qui prétend aujourd'hui être aux
avant postes avant était assez le curé
nattawut casser du musulman
c'est tellement plus confortable et
moins risqué
en prétendant que soit dix ans comme dit
le général zawi est d'ailleurs un mythe
total on aurait une sorte de l'islamisme
politique rampe en france alors qu'en
vérité l'éthique qui ont tué à charlie
hebdo ne sont que de pauvres types perdu
deux cités qui se sont trouvés une cause
mais en aucun cas ils sont politisés on
va niveau intellectuel niveau de
politisation ces trois vidéos sur
internet qu'ils ont radicalisé c'est un
peu léger
on est très très loin et la judée une
petite me sens monsieur jean messier
apps qui connaît peut-être pas bien être
humain qui avait aussi un journal
satirique qui était antisémite
violemment ces mythes la possible
peut-être que monsieur médias ne connais
pas le dr sturmer je veux juste finir
l'instant journal allemand là aussi ça
tire et antisémites violent qui pendant
quasiment 22 ans jusqu'en 45 jusqu'à la
mort de son fondateur hugh streicher
s'est autorisé à attaquer de façon
obsessionnelle et permanente c'était au
siège de bader satirique une communauté
la communauté juive
donc le fait toujours attaquer des
faibles parce qu'on revient de fait il
n'y a pas d'organisation original
structuré en france y'a pas
d'international islamistes il n'ya pas
soi disant écoutez je n'ai je pas cela
parce que c'est une c'est une vue c'est
une vue totale de l'esprit d'abord
l'antisémitisme ça n'a rien à voir avec
des caricatures du prophète je répète en
france nous avons le draw nous avons un
deux un droit d'attaquer des messages
qu'ils soient religieux ou
philosophiques académique
tant qu'on ne s'attaque pas des
individus l'antisémitisme s'attaquer à
des individus caricatures et des
individus et un soutien dans les
ingrédients et insulté et insulté une
communauté en direct alors que les
caricatures de charlie hebdo n'attaque
pas des individus ils n'attaquent pas
une communauté il attaque un message
religieux
j'ajoute que 120 km heure je doute moi
j'ajoute que quand vous dites et
s'attaque aux faibles
excusez-moi charlie hebdo s'est pas
attaqué au fait qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
sont morts en revanche on s'attaque aux
faibles effectivement quand on s'attaque
aux chrétiens et aux juifs
et là vous trouverez beaucoup de gens
courageux c'est un look et le pape pour
moquer les rabbins etc
par contre il ya effectivement vous nos
chances
je termine mon propos je termine mon
propos vous avez beaucoup parlé je
termine juste en 10 secondes
vous aurez beau vous aurez beaucoup de
gens pour critiquer et caricatures et
des chrétiens et des juifs parce que
précisément il n'y a aucun risque
l'autocensure en france vient
effectivement sur l'islam et le coran et
les prêts les figures de l'islam parce
qu'ils savent très bien que s'ils le
font eh bien il risque un coup de
couteau voir une kalachnikov et donc du
coup ils ne le font plus également que
l'appareil at-il selon vous votre
réponse une spécificité effectivement
lié à l'islam à cette religion est pas
forcément aux autres vous savez quand
pendant quarante ans que rio c'est ça me
tire on ne parle que du slam en france
c'est toujours à charge que laurent
terroristes intégristes massacreur dans
les années 80 que monsieur messier n'a
pas connu ce n'est pas que si ce n est
pas de banlieues évident 16e vous avez
80 les jeunes mamans des concurrents ce
monsieur je suis arrivée du match
d'affilée on va pas déjà fait pourquoi
liste mais n'y a eu aucune offre ne me
dit pas d'où je viens parce que vous
n'en savez rien d'accord je sais que
c'est du caire vous êtes né au coeur des
arrivées habitant en france toutes parts
pour parker c'est vous qui connaissez
vous savez que je suis arrivé je suis né
en france il avait vécu un gamin
laminage sur la question la spécificité
effectivement jean moulin à nice il n'ya
pas de spécificité france il ya
communauté de six millions de musulmans
et à six cent mille juifs est
essentiellement est à peu près 20 à 30
millions de chrétiens catholiques
puissent vouloir vendre nos solutions bi
que les chrétiens catholiques fischer
pendant des années à telle enseigne
qu'un roman des leggings à l'acte
terroriste au moment de la sortie d'un
film est ma dernière tentation du christ
on a fait sauter une bombe
tiens c'est pour le côté chrétien gentil
on va mettre ensuite le che mais chez
nous par exception
dorian nous expliquer le traitement fait
à lorient ce mal fêté ce sont les
banlieues américaines qui ont mal fait
mais très tendues régnant à l'époque qui
vit très bien moyen-orient mais au-delà
de ça pour me en france est incroyable
vont être réunies si fabuleux il faut
être très précis
vous nous parlez vous il est un fils de
diplomate riche de pauvres que vous ne
connaissez pas moi je les collèges 8 ans
moi je suis fils d'ouvrier sous-traiter
les règlements de compte personnels ça
sert à terminer sur le
faux et on arrive à la fin du débat
réviser vos pistes à rentrer des devises
tu as fais pas ton parent d'un sujet il
faut être capable de maîtriser les
termes du débat
en l'occurrence l'actionnariat est
compliqué la communauté arabo musulmane
de france ne fait que réagir à depuis 40
ans une actualité qui essaie que les
montrer du doigt secteur en allemagne à
l'éthique et la compassion allemande à
la haine pour les mêmes motifs
parce que c'était une ethnie une
religion confondues bonjour mandat le
récit sous les matelas binard
aujourd'hui les aujourd'hui les nazis ce
sont les islamistes
le fascisme rampant ces jeunes et
mécanismes la région songer à six est
unique en france
la résurgence de l'antisémitisme en
france il est liée à la montée en
puissance de l'islam politique dans
énormément de territoire quand les juifs
des territoires si mais achète un peu
éloigné du débat sur la censure mais
effectivement là vous toucher finalement
au coeur au fond du débat merci en tout
cas à tous les deux gammes alabina jean
messier d'avoir accepté ce face à face
on dirait que tu alerte et france
le ferroviaire au coeur du plan de
relance du gouvernement près de 5
milliards d'euros de ce plan iront à la
sncf le train fait son grand retour à la
faveur de la transition énergétique
il se pose comme une alternative à
l'aérien et au transport routier
mais les défis sont nombreux ouverture à
la concurrence gestion de la préco vide
au final l'entreprise publique est elle
vraiment la grande gagnante de ce plan
on obtient tel qu'un répit on en parle
tout de suite avec l'économiste jacques
sapir bienvenue jeanne bonsoir à vous
bonsoir c'est fanny alors jacques
commence présentait venir de la sncf qui
semble plutôt avantager un par ce plan
de relance présenté au début du mois oui
indiscutablement avec 4,7 milliards pour
la sncf présent dans le plan de relance
c'est une bonne nouvelle
il faut ajouter à cela évidemment que le
gouvernement a présenté une forme de
deux plans de relance de plans de
priorité pour le transport ferroviaire
il voudrait justement substituer le
train à un certain nombre de voyages en
avion relancer le fret relancer les tran
huy dont tous que ça en apparence ce
sont eux d'excellentes nouvelles sauf
que malheureusement la sncf sort du
confinement et avant de la grève qu'il y
avait eu fin 2019 début 2020 assez
affaibli et on peut se demander si elle
pourra justement profiter de cette
situation qui devrait lui être pourtant
favorable alors que représente un
jacques le volet transports au sein de
la partie transition écologique du plan
de relance
alors il faut savoir que dont le plan de
relance il ya grosso modo 30 milliards
d'euros qui sont destinées si vous
voulez à la transition écologique
sur ces 30 milliards il y en a 11
milliards qui sont destinés aux
problèmes des transports et sur ces 11
milliards justement on a les 4 7
milliards pour la sncf alors ça semble
effectivement important et d'une
certaine manière c'est d'autant plus
important que le gouvernement avant la
crise de lakovic 19 et bien a repris à
sa charge une grosse partie de la dette
de la sncf
fin 2019 la dette de la sncf s'était 60
milliards d'euros dont 52 milliards rien
que pour le réseau est là le
gouvernement
il a repris 22 milliards donc on se dit
voilà c'est un effort qui est quand même
un effort extrêmement important oui mais
quand on regarde ce que pèsent ces 4 7
milliards surtout déjà à côté des 22
milliards qui ont été décidé bien avant
la crise de lakovic 19 eh bien on peut
se dire que malgré tout il ya peut-être
une certaine ambiguïté dans la force de
ce plan alors jeanne vous dites que ces
difficultés se sont plutôt aggravées
avec le confinement
oui tout à fait pour le premier semestre
de 2020 si on regarde les les comptes de
la sncf on voit que la sncf a perdu à
peu près deux milliards 4 ce qui est
nettement plus que ce qu'elle avait
perdu dans la même époque en 2019
ce qui veut dire que l'on va se
retrouver avec 4 milliards peut-être 4
milliards 5 de déficit à la fin de
l'année à 4 milliards 5,2 déficit c'est
pratiquement la somme qui est prévu dans
le plan si vous voulez dans le plan de
relance
la somme qui est prévu dans le plan de
relance c'est 4 7 milliards et puis un
autre problème
on constate aussi toujours si on regarde
les comptes de la sncf que les
investissements ont baissé or la sncf
elle a dramatiquement besoin aujourd'hui
d'investir alors 2 quel ordre justement
ces investissements alors cet
investissement on peut les mettre dans
trois directions
tout d'abord évidemment si le
gouvernement veut que la sncf remplace
le train pour des voyages de ville en
ville par exemple sur paris toulouse
paris bordeaux
bon il va devoir investir et va devoir
investir en matériel va falloir plus de
rames de tgv va aussi falloir investir
dans le réseau il va falloir investir
dans le système de signalisation dans
les caténaires
rappelez-vous l'épisode un petit peu
dramatique où des gens qui venaient
d'hendaye ont été en tgv ont été bloqués
ils ont mis plus de 20 heures pour
revenir sur paris
bref si on veut vraiment assurer la
ponctualité
et la rapidité de ses transports oui il
faudra investir ça c'est une évidence
deuxième point c'est le développement
des lignes secondaires alors là aussi si
on veut développer les lignes
secondaires il va falloir racheter du
matériel
il va falloir des ter qui soit nettement
plus fréquents bien sûr les régions
prennent leur charge dans ses dépenses
mais il faudra de manière absolument
évident que l'état apporte je dirais ça
tiers est une pierre plutôt importante
dans ce secteur
et puis on a le problème de la relance
des trains de nuit et de la relance du
fret ferroviaire à la bombe
deux excellentes nouvelles mais il faut
savoir que les trains de nuit il y en a
pratiquement plus donc ça veut dire si
on veut vraiment relancer les trains de
nuit il faudra acheter massivement du
matériel il faudra de nouveaux
équipements
même chose pour le ferai parce que si
vous voulez la question du fret c'est
bien beau de dire qu'il faut développer
le fret ferroviaire
mais l'essentiel c'est comment on fait
passer des charges du camion au train et
puis après du train aux camions ce qu'on
appelle le transport multimodal et là
encore ça va demander des
investissements extrêmement lourd
si vous posez la question jacques ça va
coûter combien
alors si on consulte différents
instituts ou différents bureaux d'études
qui ont travaillé là dessus on aboutit à
une espèce de consensus et a dit qu'il
faudrait entre 15 et 20 milliards
d'investissements en plus des
investissements qui sont déjà prévues
pour les prochaines années
pas d'investissement global c'est
vraiment de l'investissement
supplémentaire d'ici cinq ans alors mais
vous dites aussi qu'il y à l'ouverture à
la concurrence n'est ce pas oui tout à
fait et ça il faut le savoir c'est que à
partir de la fin de 2020
l'ensemble du réseau ferroviaire sera
justement ouvert à la concurrence alors
cette ouverture à la concurrence
justement elle a déjà eu lieu dans le
domaine du fret et c'est un petit peu ça
qui en réalité a tué le fret avec la
suppression de toute une série de lignes
donc oui la concurrence ça va reposer un
problème extrêmement important à la sncf
et pour quelles raisons alors est tout
d'abord à partir du moment où il ya
concurrence est bien évidemment les
concurrents donc les différentes
sociétés qui vont assurer le transport
ferroviaire
elles vont se précipiter sur les lignes
les plus rentables et elles vont
abandonner justement les rings les
lignes qui ne sont pas rentables
or il faut savoir que le transport
ferroviaire
c'est un transport en réseau et donc si
on veut que les gens prennent le tgv
plutôt qu'ils ne prennent la voiture
eh bien il va falloir leur assurer le
transport du premier kilomètre au
dernier kilomètre
autrement dit ça veut dire qu'il faudra
bien sûr qu'il y ait les lignes de tgv
il faudra qu'il y ait des
correspondances sur des lignes de ter
qui les amène justement leur destination
le problème du transport c'est que on
voit bien que c'est justement cette
espèce de continuité du premier au
dernier kilomètre qui compte
si un opérateur de transport n'est pas
capable de fournir justement cette
espèce de continuité d'assurer les
correspondances
s'il n'en est pas capable et bien à ce
moment là les gens choisiront la voiture
est ce que l'on constate et on l'a
constaté dans plusieurs pays
c'est que la concurrence s'est très
souvent la voie la plus rapide à la
privatisation et c'est souvent la voie
la plus rapide au retour de la voiture
comme moyen de transport est donc jeanne
vous pensez que la sncf sera comme vous
dites
le dindon de la farce alors je pense
qu'il est trop tôt pour le dire mais on
peut avoir
on peut garder ce risque à l'esprit
parce que si vous voulez derrière cette
ouverture à la concurrence il ya la
privatisation
on sait très bien que l'union européenne
poussent à la privatisation injustement
et de la sncf et de l'ensemble des
opérateurs ferroviaires
or il faut aussi savoir une chose c'est
que cette privatisation à cette
concurrence ça ne marche pas la grande
bretagne qui avait été promis pionnière
justement dans le domaine de la
privatisation du secteur ferroviaire et
bien elle est revenue là dessus les
britanniques ont re nationaliser
l'ensemble des sociétés qui s'occupent
du transport ferroviaire au cui on a ce
problème et
globalement on peut se demander s'il y a
bien une cohérence entre les objectifs
qui ont été fixés par le gouvernement
objectifs qui sont tout à fait
respectable tout à fait défendable par
ailleurs et les moyens qu'il met
justement pour qu'on atteigne ses
objectifs
autrement dit donnera-t-on réellement à
la sncf les moyens financiers pour
qu'elle puisse remplir ses objectifs et
la question restera en suspens on verra
la réponse merci jacques d'avoir été en
direct restez avec nous donc quelques
instants à nous parlerons du retour des
gilet jaune sur le pavé parisien ce
samedi une centaine de rues seront
bouclées en marge de la manifestation
d'autres rassemblements sont prévus dans
toute la france alors doit-on s'attendre
à de nouveaux affrontements entre gilet
jaune et forces de police rester avec
nous arte france on en débattra
non
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité non des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui
j'ai entendu beaucoup le valais est
possédée pourquoi aujourd'hui
le président et candidat à sa propre
succession nous estimons que le
président ouattara est celui qui a le
leadership nécessaire pour faire face au
public se pose à nous tant au niveau
interne ou externe qui m'a particulier
en ce moment en côte d'ivoire et des
violences sous prétexte dont une
manifestation et d'expression du droit
démocratique
on incite à la haine on est six mètres
est-ce que sincèrement vous êtes
certains que le scrutin du 31 octobre
sera maintenu à la date prévue
il n'y a pas de raison que ce scrutin ne
soit pas maintenu
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité mais idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
usé le matin la société
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
recettes deuxième heure d'information
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 10 septembre les
gilet jaune ils font leur rentrée ce
samedi alors que plusieurs appels à
manifester ont été lancés sur les
réseaux sociaux
la préfecture de police a publié un
arrêté visant à interdire sur près d'une
centaine de rues parisiennes tout
rassemblement se revendiquant des gilet
jaune
alors à quoi faut-il s'attendre entre ce
mouvement et les forces de l'ordre
l'affrontement est il inévitable
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir la turquie au coeur du sommet euro
med 7 qui se déroule en corse et qui
réunit les représentants de sept pays du
sud de l'europe
le président français est actuellement
en train de s'exprimer ils dénoncent
notamment le jeu hégémonique de
puissance en méditerranée site en russie
et turquie
donald trump au coeur d'une nouvelle
polémique le président américain aurait
volontairement minimisé l'épidémie de
coronavirus c'est ce que révèle une
enquête menée par le journaliste
d'investigation bob woodward le
locataire de la maison blanche dit
avoir voulu éviter une panique ses
adversaires sans digne à quelques
semaines de la présidentielle
[Musique]
gérald darmanin porte plainte contre
jérôme rodrigues le ministre de
l'intérieur réagit un tweet publié hier
par l'un des meneurs des gilets jaunes
dans lequel il comparaît des policiers à
je cite une bande de nazis les détails
avec robin pu elle jérôme rodrigues ne
mâche pas ses mots envers les forces de
l'ordre ce mercredi la figure du
mouvement des gilet jaune publié un
tweet incisif en réponse à un message
provocateur du syndicat de police
synergie officiers
il qualifie ses interlocuteurs de nazis
et compare les locaux de police un camp
de concentration
jérôme rodriguez fait référence à un
commissariat du xviiie arrondissement de
paris
utilisée lorsque la police procède à des
interpellations massives
un message qui ne passe pas auprès de
gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur a fait savoir
son intention de porter plainte
les propos de monsieur rodrigues envers
la police de la république sont ignobles
au nom du ministère et pour défendre
l'honneur de tous les policiers
je dépose plainte gérald darmanin
poursuit ainsi sa politique de tolérance
zéro contre les insultes envers les
policiers
le 26 juillet dernier le ministre de
l'intérieur avait annoncé porter plainte
contre le maire europe ecologie les
verts de colombes qui avait comparé les
forces de l'ordre qui traque les
migrants aux policiers et gendarmes qui
ont participé à la rafle du vel d'hiv
des menaces de poursuites qui ne
surprennent pas jérôme rodrigues à
quelque part c'est du corporatisme c'est
normal qu'ils défendent ces policiers
c'est dommage c'est normal qu'ils
défendent ces petites demoiselles
d'honneur qui était présente armés
jusqu'aux dents autour de son mariage
elle leur doit bien ça quand même hein
c'est normal donc dans l'absolu ça me
dérange pas plus
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire me prendre
ce que j'ai plus me prendre plus qu ils
m'ont enlevé aujourd'hui dans ma vie
amusez vous en même temps que vous êtes
en train de gâcher l'argent du
contribuable pour des petites injures ce
que j'appelle les embrouilles de
sucettes et de vol de deux bonbons à la
récré je pense qu'il serait peut-être
plus intéressant de mettre dans l'argent
à améliorer aujourd'hui votre police est
de faire en sorte de virer tous ces
personnes qui mettent justement à mal
l'image de la police la tension
s'intensifie entre jérôme rodrigues et
les forces de l'ordre à quelques jours
de la reprise de la mobilisation des
gilles et jo
en rassemblement est prévu à paris le 12
septembre prochain et pour en parler
nous sommes avec jean marie bigard
humoriste bonsoir jean marie bigard
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france alors à vous ne cautionnez
pas vous les propos de jérôme rodriguez
et vous n'irez pas à la manifestation de
samedi vous avez préféré apparemment
allée à brest c'est ça oui je joue à
brest et jean contre rennes et gilet
jaune que je verrai sur place pour dire
ma solidarité avec les plus démunis et
les gens qui travaillent et qui payent
leurs impôts en y qui au chili à partir
du 5 du mois
faut pas dire du 2 ça veut dire quoi
concrètement vous seriez allé à paris
mais vous n'avez peut-être pas envie
d'être associé avec des propos vous vous
jugez peut-être un peu trop extrême ta
part de jérôme aurait gelé
c'est pire que ça je vais je condamne
absolument
et moi je suis un ami de la police la
police en ce moment et depuis beaucoup
de moi est entre le marteau et l'enclume
et et ils sont là et je connais beaucoup
bondé fondre si tu veux les lois de la
république peut pas alors tu as fait
dessus ça n'est pas possible
7 cette phrase qu'il a prononcée est
inouï
elle est condamnable c'était dur on peut
pas dire que les flics français sont des
nazis même si c'est vrai si ça s'adresse
à un seul où elle que flic c'est comme
si on condamnait la police française si
tu veux tout entière donc je ne peux pas
m'afficher avec quelqu'un dont je ne
partage pas les idées tout simplement
c'est la raison pour laquelle j rey
comme je le fais quotidiennement et
pendant toute ma tournée j'ai un comité
de gilet jaune qui m'attendent à
l'entrée de chaque salle
je joue en france et je les invite par
10 15 30 ou 40 auraient jeté des chaises
et je les invite un match et kuyt parce
qu'ils n'ont pas l'argent pour venir
rigolé pendant deux heures
jean marie bigard juste pour terminer
sur ce chapitre guéguerre police une
partie des gilets jaunes dont surtout
jérôme rodriguez effectivement vous
l'avez toujours dit je suis un ami de la
police aussi bien que je suis un ami
gilet jaune est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui à une forme
de pression médiatique peu importe qui
pousse finalement être obligé de choisir
un camp ben bien sûr bien sûr d'ailleurs
nos gouvernants connaissent par exemple
la la le cancer de toutes les
manifestations
ce sont les casseurs c'est ce qui énerve
seulement tout tout le monde les connaît
par leur nom et leur prénom avec des
centaines et centaines de caméras mais
le nos gouvernants décide de les
utiliser par exemple quand qu'ils ont
décidé de ne pas faire ce qu'il faisait
d'habitude pour protéger les champs
elysées ils ont laissé les casseurs
massacrer la plus belle avenue du monde
en se disant avec ça on va tuer les
gilet jaune mais va pas tuer
on ne tue pas la multitude et ya une
multitude de gens qui sont mécontents en
colère qui paient sans sourcilier leurs
impôts qui travaillent et qui n'arrivent
pas à joindre les deux bouts et cela je
suis avec eux et je le montrerai quand
j'arriverai à brest pour jouer un
guipavas samedi et bien je tombe en est
forcément sur un comité de gilet jaune
du jeune saluer tu inviterait comme je
le fais tous les jours je le faisais
avant le point noir dont qu'il puisse
assister
hamon suite alors effectivement ça tu
rentrais ce samedi en tout cas marque le
retour des manifestations de gilet jaune
j'ai eu cette période de confinement
comment justement vous percevez l'avenir
est ce que entre guillemets pour vous
les choses empirent ce mouvement va
s'amplifier marqué le pas restée égale
quel est votre sentiment
je pense que ce qui va nous arriver va
être terrible c'est à dire la colère
qu'on n'a pas écouté du peuple va
revenir à nos gouvernants comme un
élastique et ça va être très très fort
nos gouvernants ne savent pas que on n'a
pas le droit de mépriser le peuple à ce
point et je pense qu'ils vont le
comprendre dans les mois qui viennent
alors beaucoup d'arrêter un préfectoraux
vous le savez ont été pris pour
interdire la manifestation dans certains
secteurs dans de nombreuses rues à paris
on n'oublie pas qu'on est en pleine
crise sanitaire
est ce qu'on doit s'entendre s'attendre
on vous le craignez en tout cas un face
à face avec la police
c'est vraisemblable puisque cote quand
on refuse d'ouvrir la porte
évidemment tu es un peu tendance à la
défoncer la la violence et éviers
intimement avec toutes les
manifestations populaires
c'est impossible autrement donc il est
vraisemblable que on s'achemine vers
beaucoup de rancoeur et beaucoup de
violence de part et d'autre alors vous
vous défendez effectivement les
revendications premières un dg des
jaunes plus de justice plus d'égalité de
démocratie pouvoir d'achat il ya quand
même eu quelques appels sur facebook
en dénonçant de la part de gilet jaune
en dénonçant une dictature sanitaires et
celle de l'obligation du port du masque
qui se sont rajoutés à ses
revendications habituelles est ce que
vous vous cautionnez ça écoutez on vit
on a masqué 7 milliards de personnes sur
la planète alors que nous avons
aujourd'hui je parle pas de mars dernier
nous avons aujourd'hui un virus qui un
peu moribond qui se soigne très bien
nous avons deux traitements par deux
médecins français cocorico
tu vois qu'ils soignent n'importe quelle
personne en quelques jours et on
condamne la terre entière à porter un
masque et c'est absolument scandaleux et
je ne sais pas quand je vous parle à qui
profite le crime
ce que je sais c'est que c'est
insupportable de savoir que des médecins
comme le professeur raoul tu ou comme
sabine pas liens franco tous les deux
avec deux pour seul est d'ailleurs un
petit peu différent soigne à 100% les
gens et que on continue à nous obliger à
obliger 7 milliards de personnes à
porter un masque
c'est une une choses incohérentes et je
la dénonce aujourd'hui devant vous je
veux dire dans ma vie car je tiens à
préciser parce que sinon je serais pas
dans mon rôle qu effectivement c'est
votre avis est votre opinion
les chiffres sont inquiétants concernant
le coronavirus certains voilà bons coups
en tout cas a dit ce qu'il pense que le
traitement valable et évidemment les
autorités soutiennent port du masque et
voilà l'obligation de porter de masque
cela est
qui dit fois un coup dans la science un
coup dans l'autre on nous a dit le
masque c'est dangereux
après on nous a dit il est obligatoire
qu'est ce que les français peuvent
penser de ça une chose est sûre c'est
que les gens qui sont soignés avec les
deux traitements que je viens de citer à
81,19 forçant évite le buteur et le mort
et voilà on a cassé votre avis merci
jean marie bigard d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france et de nous avoir
à exprimer votre opinion
partout en france les gilet jaune sont
de retour donc on le disait à toulouse
lyon lille nantes et marseille entre
autres plusieurs appels à manifester ont
été lancés en douce étant sous haute
surveillance
nadège abderrazak les gilet jaune
vont-ils réussir leur rentrée sur les
réseaux sociaux il semble en tout cas
prêt à redescendre dans les rues
puisque des appels à manifester ont été
lancés un peu partout en france
à paris quatre manifestations sont
prévues pour la première le rendez vous
est donné à 9 heures sur les champs
elysées est la deuxième ce sera 10
heures place de la bourse mais meurt
pour la troisième en revanche ça sera
place wagram la quatrième à 13 heures
place saint pierre et sur ces quatre
manifestations
trois sont d'ores et déjà interdite au
vu j'ai site des risques des troubles à
l'ordre public
le préfet de police a interdit les
rassemblements se revendiquant du
mouvement des gilet jaune à compter du
vendredi 11 septembre à 18 heures dans
plusieurs secteurs de la capitale ainsi
que deux manifestations ce samedi 12
septembre
parmi les secteurs concernés par ces
interdictions figurent notamment lé
champs elysées l'assemblée nationale
matignon
la préfecture de police ou encore le
champ de mars mais qu'importe
l'interdiction certains gilet jaune
veulent un retour aux sources s'est
manifesté là où tout a commencé sur les
champs elysées j'appelle à une
démolition
complète je vous invite ce jour là à ne
montrer aucune carte d'identité
quitte à aller faire un petit tour au
commissariat pour une vérité identité et
qui passait quatre heures entre en
perdre un oeil et les faire chier
appliquer la désobéissance civile
hashtag désobéissance civile
un appel à la désobéissance civile qui
est loin de faire l'unanimité et qui
suscite même la moquerie d'autres
leaders du mouvement où il les avait
prévenus de votre évolution
elle est bien au chaud au s'asseoir
quand tu t'en es ma team au commissariat
le fait d exil fera demi tour avec le
sandwich on va te l'envoyer au comico
c'est pas grave qui reste quatre heures
et la révolution espace au commissariat
ouais
cette dissensions persistent depuis des
mois et elle ont peut-être même pesé
dans l'essoufflement du mouvement des
gilet jaune
quoi qu'il en soit tout l'enjeu de ce 12
septembre c'est d'évaluer si un nouveau
souffle est encore possible
l exécutif craint un retour de flamme et
pour cause la gestion du gouvernement de
la crise sanitaire a amplifié la colère
sociale
on dit qu'il ya la seconde vague du coc
vide
il va y avoir la seconde vague gilet
jaune de hashtag 12 septembre
et ouais c'est une date très importante
ça va montrer le mécontentement de la
population comme
on peut le voir en ce moment c'est
délicat dans notre pays la rentrée sera
quand même très très très revendicatif
il ya des préoccupations qu'attendent
les français aujourd'hui c'est comment
vivre dignement et on avait toujours
demandé qu' un grenelle du poids d'achat
qui soit fait un pour un grenelle 3
d'achat économiques et fiscales qui sont
organisées par l'état pour savoir si
aujourd'hui avec son salaire on peut
vivre dignement la démission des manuels
macron est toujours réclamé tout comme
les demandes pour plus de justice
sociale fiscales et environnementales
dans le détail les gilet jaune réclame
300 euros de plus pour les bas salaires
les retraites et les aides sociales
l'essence à 1 euro ou encore la
libération de plus de 800 manifestants
qualifié de prisonniers politiques
ray c'est donc un week-end de tensions
qui se prépare avec la possibilité que
les antilles masque se greffent au
mouvement c'est notre question ce soir
gilet jaune policiers l'affrontement est
il inévitable c'est l'objet de notre
face à face et pas de dingle pour en
débattre
nous sommes
en direct avec bruno bartocetti
secrétaire national délégué zone sud
unité sgp police et puis dans quelques
instants c'est linda bigot ans j'ai les
jambes qui va nous rejoindre en direct
par téléphone on a un petit soucis de
connexion on va commencer avec vous au
bruno bartocetti est ce que vous
craignez justement de grosses tensions
alors que l'on sait notamment dans la
capitale que plusieurs rues et bien sont
interdites à la manifestation ce samedi
en soirée merci de m'avoir fait partie
les manifestations des gis légendes vont
entraîner peut-être dix des trente mille
personnes partout en france mais on
pouvait gérer deux millions de personnes
dans les rues à 204 les caisses pour
parler de la dernière de manifestations
mais là d'un prétexte comme 95 par
exemple que vous aviez un 1,80
sécuritaire autour de donner des noms
communs des manifestations mais là quand
on parle souvent vides et gilet jaune et
avec tout le respect que l'on doit au
gilet jaune
on condamne bien évidemment ce qui est
un filtre ce mouvement de gilet jaune
pourra faire mouvement de violence
urbaine
donc bien sûr concret ce mouvement là
mais nous saurons pas rim seront
préparés pour empêcher de voir évoluer
ces violences urbaines promet le zoo
évolué depuis
depuis quelques quelques années salez
notre organisation c'est au début le
mouvement des gilets jaunes ni gilet
jaune aujourd'hui n'existe pas comme on
n'existe plus comme on dirait au tout
début de rassemblement
aujourd'hui vous dit vous êtes paré
voilà pour ces violences urbaines les
consignes ont-elles changé quelles
sont-elles aujourd'hui de la part des
autorités envers la police
mais toute façon elles seront adaptées
aux situations on peut pas parler d'un
changement maintenant les forces de
l'ordre sauront se rendre à nombre
une quarantaine d'autres unités de
forces mobiles plus les compagnies de
police de paris puis partout en france
on aime on est préparé à ceux-ci de
toute façon ne fléchira pas face au
petit vent les violences urbaines et on
s'adaptera aux situations il est hors de
question d'accepter aujourd'hui c'est à
dire notre république est d'ailleurs
j'espère qu'on va y revenir puisque la
violence elle commence dans les mots et
les maux qui ont été tenus par ses
doutes et je ne sais pas si mal en tête
mais les mots qui ont été tenus par par
jérôme rodriguez sont une insulte pour
la république s'il se revendique leader
des gilet jaune
je regrette qu'il ait gilet jaune à tout
âge à trouver quelle personne ne l'ont
pas n'est ce pas un leader en tant que
tel parce que c'est une insulte c'est
une provocation gratuite et est au
départ les jeunes ne partait pas dans ce
schéma là pour provoquer ou insulté la
police
nous nous sommes là pour faire respecter
les règles la loi et nous irons jusqu'au
bout entre chira pas de bain devant des
personnes aussi abjecte que ce monsieur
effectivement germain rodriguez 1 qui a
traité certains d'entre eux la police de
bande de nazes il est au coeur de cette
nouvelle polémique 1 sur les réseaux
sociaux après ce tweet invectivant voilà
vos collègues
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur à un porté plainte je vous
propose de l'écouter on va écouter
jérôme rodriguez l'instant aux nazis
vous irez ouvrir le camp de
concentration disponibles au nord-est de
paris celui que vous tentez de cacher
aux médias et voilà c'était donc le son
de 2 jérôme rodriguez que vous avez déjà
entendu gérald darmanin qui porte
plainte c'est un minimum pour vous bruno
bartocetti c'est au minimum une réaction
immédiate de la part de notre ministre
j'espère que la justice va sanctionner
sévèrement parce que ne peut pas
accepter aujourd'hui dans une république
ça l'est dans les rangs de la police
vous avez des vous avez des des
policiers qui ont des petits fils ou
fils de déportés de résistants des juifs
parmi nous
on peut accepter une telle provocation
ce n'est même pas de provocation c'est
même pas une insulte c'est pire que ça
je saluerai si je peux si je peux le
faire je salue les propos de jean-marie
bigard les stars je suis convaincu que
les gilets jaunes dans l'ensemble
condamne jérôme rodrigues en tout cas je
l'espère et même si on peut regretter
son parcours au cdj les jeunes puisqu'il
a été victime une défense jécistes
défense de la part des policiers sans
viser son oeil ce n'est pas parce qu'il
a été blessé qui doit s'autoriser à et
zulte et l'institution a insulté les
policiers où il a fait ça va même plus
loin qu'une insulte c'est une c'est
vraiment un site
j'ai envie de calais qualifiés ceux ci
de crime moral vous voyez c'est grave de
tenir ce genre de propos et sa salle et
le mouvement des gilet jaune vous savez
que ce soit 68 1995 1984 c'était sur les
écoles privées vous aviez deux millions
de personnes dans la rue est ce qu'ils
croient maintenant ce genre de propos
qui va rassembler du monde autour de lui
c'est impossible
la phrase est une et une pays
républicain respectueux de ses règles et
on a trop souffert pour en reparler de
cet individu de la sorte alors c'est
vrai que les propos sont sans fard mono
bateau de shetty il n'empêche qu'on se
doit de rappeler que jérôme rodriguez a
tout de même perdu un oeil lors d'une
manifestation après avoir été visé par
un flash-ball à défaut évidemment de
cautionner ces propos est-ce que vous
pouvez comprendre une forme de colère
chez une partie des gilet jaune dont
d'ailleurs jérôme rodriguez qui a été
blessé à vis des pc mais nous n'avons
pas visé le policier lorsqu'il utilise
son sol bdc sont lanceurs de boules de
défense ne vise pas un et c'est
impossible c'est un peu comme un bras
arraché on ne le dit pas policiers sur
une manifestation pour arracher le bras
des et des manifestants lorsqu'on envoie
une une grenade de désencerclement c'est
pour écarter justement les casseurs et
manifestants lorsqu on rejette des
manifestants en tout cas d'être chaude
aux manifestants violents c'est pour se
défendre
on va pas me chercher des cas isolés je
parle d'une manière générale parce que
vous avez aujourd'hui dans nos rangs de
nuit le policier blessé je vous dis bien
de 2000 policiers blessés seulement dans
les manifestations
j'ai alors qu'on a des casques et
boucliers c'est qu'on est visé avec des
boules de pétanque avec des projectiles
qui pourrait nous tuer si on avait passé
on utiliserait notre arme de service en
matière de légitime défense et on ne
pouvait pas nous le reprocher donc
aujourd'hui si on doit retenir plus loin
que des blessures on doit retenir qu'on
a aux deux familles en deuil et le
aujourd'hui c'était au début des
mouvements de jeunes pourquoi parce que
les manifestations étaient anarchique
non encadrés la violence ne s'exerce pas
de la part de la police
ils ont recentré le débat il ne faut pas
se tromper de cible
on il a sécurisé d'un manifestant et on
a des casseurs il vient au milieu qui
provoque qui vont jusqu'à vouloir tuer
du policier c'est ça la réalité ils
viennent ponctuer du policier
ils ne viennent même pas pour
revendiquer aujourd'hui nouveau ses
dessins et ses cibles ou autre chose
puisque quand on leur demande quel est
le message principal c'est de parler de
désobéissance et d'aller au petit les
filles peuvent aller commissariat voilà
mon objectif je vous interromps parce
que linda bigot mieux vaut tard que
jamais on a eu un petit souci technique
gilet jaune à nous a rejoint pour ce qui
était initialement un débat ce sont les
aléas du direct
nda bigot j'imagine vous avez écouté
bruno bartocetti on évoque évidemment
cette affaire avec jérôme rodriguez qui
a eu des mots évidemment très dur un
band de nazis en qualifiant les les
policiers bruno bartocetti voilà qui se
défendent et voilà de ces violences
policières présumées en disant que
souvent voilà c'était une réponse à des
attaques de la part d'eads et gillet
jose en faisant référence notamment à la
perte de l'oeil de jérôme rodriguez
on parlait aussi de ces nouvelles
tensions qui sont craintes pour les
nouvelles manifestations à partir de
samedi
vous les craignez vous aussi c'est
ces tensions avec la police tout d'abord
je vais répondre à monsieur bartoli 6 à
bonsoir match et parce que j'ai bart
autres et il part donc excusé moi j'ai
un peu suivi
là on a eu des problèmes techniques donc
j'ai un peu suivi ce que vous avez dit
depuis tout à l'heure une chose est sûre
c'est que le sujet hambourg de riez pas
relance pour nous prendre ça c'est une
chose
par contre que j'apprécie moins c'est
quand que vous essayez de généraliser et
de stigmatiser absolument les gilet
jaune en pas en parlant de nous comme
étant des violents au noir il s'est mal
terminée monsieur j'ai au moins de
rigueur a peut-être parlé sous le coup
de l'émotion parce que il s'est senti
attaqué certes personnellement par
lhenry en mon nom je ne cautionne pas
ces propos je pense qu'il aurait
peut-être dû développer autrement
puisqu'il subit des attaques sur les
réseaux sociaux
en attendant faut pas oublier que sur
rodriguez et quand même un éborgné sur
30 ont été épargnés d'autres personnes
ont été mutilés n'oublions pas un de vos
confrères syndicaliste qui s'est
ouvertement moqué d'un jeune homme
sébastien mallet qui a perdu la main
alors vous parlez d'armement que vous
utilisez ceci cela ceci cela mais en
attendant nous n'essayons pas de
détourner l'attention
les armements que vous utilisez sondés
sont qualifiés d armement de guerre
cela a mutilé à épargner des personnes
sans compter des violences à outrance
des pacifistes ont été martyrisés
notamment je parle à mélanie je pense à
mélanie menadi qui a pris un coup de
matraque
derrière la tête qui en gardent des
séquelles parlons aussi de l'assaut de
cette unité de crs qui est entré dans le
burger king et matraques et de gilets
jaunes pacifique en l'occurrence vous ne
vous êtes pas allé à attaquer à des soi
disant casseurs mais bel et bien des
pacifistes monsieur certes ce qui a été
tenu dans les réseaux sociaux n'est pas
cautionner à bhl et cela n'engage que
monsieur monsieur rodriguez mais vous ne
pouvez pas généraliser stigmatiser
encore plus le mouvement des gilets
jaunes en dix ans que vous craignez des
violences à venir
on ne connaît pas l'avenir on ne connaît
pas l'avenir bruno bâton cassé votre vin
réponse on ne va pas malheureusement
pouvoir rester trop longtemps puisque on
arrivait à la fin du débat à pardonner
nous in the big o votre réponse tout de
même voilà ces propos alors oui d'abord
elle a répondu aux questions
j'insiste sur le fait que ni sommes
notre organisation syndicale à avoir été
les premiers à soutenir jécistes bien
lorsqu'il y avait 4 et s'isoler très
très isolée de flics qui ont dérapé
ces derniers ont fait l'objet d'une
enquête igpn et ont été sanctionnés donc
moi ce que je reproche c'est qu'on
remette en cause l'institution s'était
passé combien je continue dans les
forêts après le dépôt important à
mireval chez les jaunes j'ai parce que
comme gilet jaune pour le moment et sur
des progressions de ma passion des
pinasses parce qu'un flic arrivé le
matin pour prendre son service
ce n'est pas beaucoup merci à tous les
deux merci à tous les deux parce qu'on
peut se la qualité du son est
extrêmement mauvaise inda bigot si on
policière
pardon inzaghi go bruno bartocetti merci
à vous en tout cas pour ceux 2000 face à
face on va dire en tout cas d'avoir
accepté cette
cette contradiction dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous parlerons
du médecin est encore sur les chefs
d'état de sept pays méditerranée se sont
rassemblées aujourd'hui pour notamment
évoquer les tensions entre la grèce et
la turquie et puis nous parlerons de
donald trump et duco vip le président
américain a admis qu'il avait minimisé
la gravité du corps des virus
[Musique]
bandol convergent
vous avez découvert que l'imagerie
médicale qui était le coeur de votre
métier avait une dimension artistique me
suis aperçu que c'était l'art qui
faisait avancer la science et la science
qui faisait avancer là l'image est belle
mais mais en général le mal qu'elle
révèle
il est terrifiant au moment du coc vite
quand j'ai attrapé moi même
la balle a dit je me suis dit mais
pourquoi j'utilise pas ma technique de
droite et de bière ton life a pour mon
thorax propres et pour le virus j'ai pu
suivre son évolution
comment auriez ça s'aggravait ou au
contraire comment ça c'est mac tu es
quand on a découvert le coït on sait qu
on sait comment ils et comment
quelle couleur il est qu'on a découvert
le mal les mèches du mal
[Musique]
il est 21h30 soyez les bienvenus en
direct sur rt france les tensions en
méditerranée orientale au coeur du
sommet du médecin qui se déroule en
corse ajaccio accueille depuis cet après
midi cette alliance informelle qui
réunit sept pays méditerranéens membres
de l'union européenne
une rencontre présidée par emmanuel
macron le chef de l'état français
appelle l'europe à plus d'unité de
clarté face à la turquie qu'il dit ne
plus considérer comme un partenaire
ankara de son côté l'accusent de mettre
en péril les intérêts de l'europe
écoutez à ce sujet la présidente de la
le président la république
le deuxième grand sujet que nous avons
abordé c'est évidemment celui de la
méditerranée orientale et de la relation
avec la turquie est au fond notre
objectif c'est véritablement de
restaurer des relations normales qui
permettent la stabilité dans la région -
avec la turquie d'obtenir la fin des
actions unilatérales de pouvoir obtenir
la fin des forages évidemment un plein
respect des de l'embargo sur les armes
pour l'ensemble des puissances de la
région en libye et d'accepter que sur
les désaccords qui existent dans la
région
la manière de les régler doit être
négocié et devant les enceintes
internationales
pour ce qui est des débats juridiques
qui sont les nôtres nous avons la
détermination de réengager ce dialogue
en coopération mais l'exigence aussi que
nos principes soient respectés dans la
durée je suis convaincu aussi que l'
échange entre l'union européenne et la
turquie est bénéfique pour les deux
parties il ya un agenda économique il ya
un agenda des changes énergétique qui
peut être retrouvé et c'est notre
souhait collectif exigences volonté d
escalade avec des principes simples et
claires que nous avons réaffirmé parce
qu aucun dialogue n'est possible s'il
repose sur un abandon de souveraineté ou
une faiblesse coupable
et pour en parler de ce sommet nous
sommes avec un morad el hattab
géopolitologue bonsoir morad el hattab
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur
arte france emmanuel macron qui vient
donc de s'exprimer à l'issue de cette
journée le président de la république
qui dénonce je cite le jeu hégémonique
de puissance en méditerranée site en
russie et turquie
capbreton comprendre messieurs mesdames
attentisme stratégique en tant qu il n'a
aucune crédibilité
excusez moi de vous le dire puisque
quand bien même j'ai des points d'accord
avec le président tueur sur la question
de la libye et sur la question de la
basilique sainte-sophie historiquement
pour être honnête
les grecs sont si proches de la turquie
sont un ensemble géostratégique un non
sens diplomatique
c'est un nid de crise diplomatique tout
le monde sait que la turquie fera 3 km
de ses côtes
la zone économique exclusive turquie hip
hop etc et par la présence de ces îles
grecques et au lieu de se comporter
comme le fait actuellement le président
de république française
il devrait permettre une entente
possible réfléchi entre un partage
équitable sur les ressources
énergétiques entre la grèce et la
turquie
mais en taxant de prime abord les turcs
comme maintenant plus des partenaires
monsieur macro et hors jeu et comme vous
l'avez rappelé ça reste une rencontre
informelle le restera informel alors ça
c'était avant le sauve est effectivement
la france qui disait qu'il ne
considérait plus la turquie comme des
partenaires il n'empêche
à l'issue de ce sommet un la discussion
apaisant peut-être un petit peu les
choses des pays du medh 7 affirmé qu'il
voulait rien engagé un dialogue de bonne
foi avec la turquie nous a dit emmanuel
macron est ce que vous croyez
ce dialogue de bonne foi encore possible
écoutez je suis un garçon dit jean
plancher un dialogue avec quelqu'un je
commence pas par l'insulté par un beau
jeu dire ce rétropédalage parce que
quelques peut-être que quelques-uns de
ses conseillers de l'ombre nous ont
avertis de la réponse
dix minutes affaires étrangères turc qui
l'a taxé d' arrogant et c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être ce qu'il a vu son comportement
moi je suis vraiment décontenancé par le
manque de de crédit que la france a de
plus en plus dès que monsieur mené
macron prend la parole lors je comprends
qu'ils recherchent le statut rhin
toujours été tendre envers l'europe et
notamment la france à linverse il faut
il faut remettre les choses à leur place
quand même je voudrais pas en crochet
mans l'attitude de pain de prendre d
accord avec monsieur erdogan
mais pour le coup il agit de manière
souveraine je peux pas me répéter ces
îles c'est un non sens géostratégique il
farah 3 km de ses côtes
on a l'impression que les navires turcs
les forages sur ce fond plein milieu de
la méditerranée ce n'est pas le cas et
c'est ça qu'il faut remettre en place
les turcs économiquement ne vont pas
accepter de serre associées par des pays
environnants
alors que à trois kilomètres de leurs
côtes ils ont largement du gaz pour
devenir autosuffisants alors
qu'aujourd'hui on exporte 80 ça
n'apporte du 90 % c'est de la logique
mais monsieur macro ne peut pas
comprendre les logiques souveraine
et comme il ya de graves problèmes en
interne il essaie de jouer de la stature
internationale mais il faut qu'il arrête
il passe son temps à insulter tous les
dirigeants étrangers
et je rappelle ya pas qu emmanuel macron
un an à delta bas il ya les sept pays
qui étaient présents qui ce soir
clairement c'est l'une des annonces à
l'issue de ce sommet soutiendrait des
sanctions économiques supplémentaires
contre la turquie si celle-ci jeu s'ils
persistaient dans ses actions
unilatérales en méditerranée orientale
votre réaction ils ne sont pas fondées
elles faire c'est une forme d'ingérence
complètement mais attendez on dit que
sept pays un intérêt 90 ou jour on se
parle il n'y a que l'armée grecque et
l'armée française sur zone
les six autres les cinq autres pays que
nous venons d'évoquer
on logique tout autre aujourd'hui suivez
maniema quand on passe t'il hilton du
poing sur la table ne pas sortir dans
les champs
par rapport à cette réunion informelle
mais encore une fois et le maniema kron
dans ses réponses n'est pas à la hauteur
je vous signale que sur la question de
la libye lequel est censé être au coeur
de cette réunion qu'est ce qu'il en est
sorti
rien sur la question des migrants rien
sur la question du colline à rien il
fait une fixation sur la turbie mais ça
risque de nous coûter très cher je vous
dis encore une fois je suis en désaccord
profond avec la turquie sur la libye sur
la basilique sainte sophie
mais pour ce qui est de deux forages
turcs en mer méditerranée
vous savez comme moi historiquement
c'est un non sens et géostratégiques et
diplomatique cette année à crise
diplomatique
ces histoires d'îles grecques donc tout
le monde est au courant et emmanuel
macron doit se comporter en chef d'état
il faut qu'il cesse absolument de
s'ingérer partout il a été le valais du
fmi au liban on orient l'a très mal pris
il s'est comporté de manière odieuse
avec loukachenko odieuse avec vladimir
poutine dans la sphère navalni qui est
un opposant pays par des puissances
étrangères dont derrière donald trump a
dit qu'on n'a toujours pas trouvé le
poison de son empoisonnement donc et que
monsieur macron s'occupe des affaires
internes
il ya beaucoup à faire en france s'ils
commencent sérieusement à agacer tout le
monde
merci morad el hattab d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous apporter votre point de
vue après ce sommet m 7 qui a eu lieu en
corse où je cite emmanuel macron a
dénoncé le jeu hégémonique de puissance
en méditerranée citons la russie et la
turquie
le médecin qui se dit favorable à de
nouvelles sanctions économiques si la
turquie
poursuivez ces élections unilatérales en
méditerranée orientale
il a aussi été question de la politique
migratoire de l'union européenne après
l' incendie qui a dévasté le camp de
réfugiés de moria sur l'île de lesbos en
grèce le plus grand camp de réfugiés du
pays hébergées quelques près de 13000
demandeurs d'asile dont 4000 enfants
ces quatre fois sa capacité d'accueil la
commission européenne a annoncé qu'elle
prenait en charge le transmet refaire
immédiat vers la grèce continentale de
400 enfants et adolescents de son côté
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
confirme ce soir une autre initiative de
paris et berlin cette fois-ci 400 autres
migrants mineurs non accompagnés seront
répartis entre les pays de l'ue eux qui
se rallieront à cette démarche
dice a dit charlie sheen grille ne s'est
demandé au premier ministre grec la
manière dont nous pourrions aider et sa
demande a été de prendre en particulier
les mineurs arrivée sur le continent
grecque
nous avons pris contact avec la france
l'allemagne et la france y participeront
j'espère que d'autres états membres de
l'ue eux le feront tegan and english
enfin hygrométrie chat nord
en tout cas nous pouvons résoudre ce
problème quand semble donc dans un
premier temps ne commenceront par
l'offre faite à la grèce pour les
réfugiés mineurs et d'autres étapes
doivent suivre pour une responsabilité
commune
l'allemagne a accepté cette
responsabilité mais nous ne pouvons pas
nous contenter d'une politique
européenne en matière de migration au
fond cela n'existe pas aujourd'hui
et si cela continue ce sera un lourd
fardeau pour l'europe et c'est pourquoi
nous allons profiter de notre présidence
du conseil de l'ue eux pour faire des
progrès dans ce domaine
à deux mois de l'élection présidentielle
américaine donald trump se retrouve à
nouveau au coeur d'une polémique dans un
ouvrage un journaliste accuse d'avoir
volontairement minimisé la gravité de la
pandémie aux états unis les précisions
de quentin mauclair un peu plus de 50
jours du scrutin présidentiel la gestion
de la crise de donald trump refait
surface à l'origine des révélations du
watergate
dans les années 1970 le journaliste bob
woodward écrit dans son nouveau livre
reage que le président américain était
au courant de la dangerosité du virus
dès le début de l'épidémie cela passe
par les airs c'est toujours plus dur que
le toucher tu n'as pas à toucher les
choses pas vrai mais l'air tu respires
juste l'air et c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et c'est donc une question très
délicate
c'est une question très délicate c'est
même plus mortel que votre grippe
fatigante
j'ai toujours voulu minimiser le danger
j'aime toujours le minimiser parce que
je ne veux pas semer la panique
c'est une chose horrible c'est
incroyable c'est si facilement
transmissible vous ne le croiriez même
pas le virus n'a rien à voir avec moi ce
n'est pas de ma faute c'est la chine qui
a laissé ce foutu virus se répandre
devant ces révélations la maison blanche
a tenu à réagir mercredi à l'occasion
d'une conférence de presse
ce président fait ce que font les
dirigeants les bons dirigeants à savoir
rester calme et résolue à un moment où
vous faites face à un défi insurmontable
c'est ce que ce président a fait donc à
l'écouté de ces enregistrements il
n'apparaîtra pas que le président a
menti au public américain le président
l'a jamais menti au public américain sur
locaux vides 19 le président a montré
qu'il était resté calme et ses actions
le reflète
habib semaines du scrutin présidentiel
joe biden ne séduit pas fait prier pour
enfoncer son rival dans cette nouvelle
polémique
il avait les informations il savait
combien c'était dangereux
et tandis que cette maladie mortelle
ravagé notre pays il n'a pas rempli sa
mission
il s'agit d'une trahison du peuple
américain sur une question de vie ou de
mort une fois de plus de l'unc trump est
donc dans la tourmente
et alors que sa gestion de crise est
critiquée de part et d'autre l'actuelle
situation sanitaire ne plaide pas non
plus en sa faveur et plus de 190 1800
mort du co vite 19 les états unis
présentent en effet
le bilan le plus élevé au monde et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
new york avec calais maupin
correspondant verte et aux états unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir calais maupin merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france donald
trump qui a donc reconnu un qu'il était
au courant de la gravité du coronavirus
dès le début du mois de février et qu'il
avait volontairement minimiser le danger
c'est une révélation de taille comment
est elle accueillie aux états unis hier
qu'il essayait d'éviter une panique
qu'il a essayé de changer leurs discours
pour se recentrer sur le fait que
beaucoup de retard attendu avant de
révéler ces informations
donald trump essaye donc de détourner la
conversation et il dit qu'il s'agit
d'une tentative d'influencer le résultat
des élections mais pour beaucoup
d'américains ça ne change rien et
effectivement la gestion de crise de
donald trump semble être au centre des
préoccupations électorales des américain
donald trump est en retard dans beaucoup
de sondages et beaucoup d'américains ont
l'intention de voter pour joe byden
plutôt que donald trump
cependant ce n'est pas le vote populaire
qui détermine le président des états
unis
mais les grands électeurs et il y aura
certes un état clé pour déterminer le
président et certains de ces états clés
sont encore des bastions du président
des états comme loyaux le michigan le
risque ainsi nous la pennsylvanie malgré
l'opposition grandissante et sa chute
dans les sondages de popularité
la situation reste encore en suspens
alors vous dites effectivement vouliez
cette affaire à la présidentielle vous
avez bien raison parce que l'affairé
grave tout de même donald trump
continuera de dire publiquement que le
virus n'est pas pire que la grille
la situation est sous contrôle ou encore
que le nombre de cas sera bientôt de 2,0
clairement à ce qu'on peut se poser la
question est-ce qu'il a mis les
américains en danger avec son attitude
j'en suis certain c'était inacceptable
dans une telle période dans une telle
crise
il est intolérable de recevoir d un
message aussi discordants de la part des
différents médias et des différentes
autorités
je trouve le comportement de donner 30
noms également d'autres figurent
d'autres personnalités qui essayait qui
étaient censés informer le corps
je trouve leur comportement intolérable
leurs actions et leurs paroles ne
correspondait pas à ce qui était
nécessaire
nous aurions dû bénéficier de toutes les
informations nécessaires et la gestion
de crise aurait pu être bien meilleur si
le système américain le système de santé
avaient tous bénéficié des mêmes
informations
donald trump se défend en disant qu'il
essayait d'éviter la panique qui ne
voulait pas faire souffrir les marchés
boursiers donald trump était inquiet il
pensait que s'il ne misait pas la
situation alors cela heureux tu eu un
impact sur la bourse américaine
et pourtant l'économie a déjà beaucoup
souffert donc je pense que beaucoup
d'américains n'accepteront pas cet
argument et pourtant il a encore
beaucoup de soutien il ya beaucoup de
personnes dans des états clés qui
considère que donald trump et leurs
défenseurs face à ce qu'ils considèrent
comme l'establishment américain
donc on ne sait pas vraiment si cela va
influencer le résultat des élections
mais donald trump a déjà prouvé qu'il
était un président problématique que ces
actions n'étaient pas dignes
en tout cas il continua sa communication
par rapport à cette crise sanitaire
on le sent en fonction de la
présidentielle puisque la désormais il
promet aux américains avec ça avant le 3
novembre
il a également retiré les aux états unis
des efforts pour développer un vaccin y
voit internationale et il ya des
tensions très fortes entre les états
unis et le ms mac competo continue à
dire que c'est la chine qui est
responsable de cette pandémie et qu'elle
devrait payer cdu
la stratégie de l'administration est
assez brouillonne s'il voulait
développer un vaccin rapidement alors on
pourrait penser qu'il souhaiterait
coopérer avec non seulement la chine
également le hamas tous les pays du
monde
cependant l'idéologie nationaliste et
isolationnistes de l'administration trup
conditionnent leurs actions donc
effectivement les décisions sont très
confuses et il ya beaucoup de programmes
différents au sein de la maison blanche
beaucoup de courants politiques
différents beaucoup de courants
politiques différence sur lequel donald
trump a construit sa coalition
merci caleb maupin d'avoir été avec nous
correspondons verte et aux états unis
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir le
retrait des troupes américaines au
moyen-orient en lui s'accélère
washington va réduire ses effectifs
militaires en irak 2200 soldats devrait
prochainement quitter le pays
il s'agit d'une des promesses de
campagne de donald trump qui va briller
donc un second mandat on l' a dit dans
quelques semaines retour en images sur
la présence américaine en irak en 2003
cent cinquante mille soldats américains
sont déployés sur le territoire
ya une date qui marque le début de la
guerre d'irak et la chute du président
saddam hussein le président américain
george w.bush décide d'envoyer des
milliers de soldats supplémentaires en
irak
les effectifs militaires américains
atteignent 165 mille j'y aille sur le
sol irakien
en 2008 la barre des 4000 militaires
américains tués en irak est atteinte les
manifestations anti guerre se
multiplient partout aux états unis la
maison blanche annonce le retrait de
8000 soldats d'irak
dans le même temps 4500 militaires
américains sont déployés en afghanistan
barack obama hostiles à la guerre en
irak promet de retirer la majorité de
ses soldats d'ici le courant de l'année
2010 le départ annoncé de l'armée
américaine coïncide avec le début d'une
importante crise politique en irak
suite à la prise de contrôle des jeux
dans plus de deux régions d'irak les
états unis s'impliquent de nouveau
militairement
plusieurs soldats sont déployés pour
bombarder les positions dédia tistes à
la suite d'un bombardement américain
contre une coalition paramilitaires
chiite des milliers d'irakiens s'en
prennent à l'ambassade des états unis
située à bagdad le général iranien
qassem suleimani et l'irakien abou mehdi
al -10 chef adjoint du hhk by meurent
suite à une frappe de drone américain à
bagdad
dans la foulée le parlement irakiens
votent en faveur de l'expulsion des
troupes étrangères d'irak washington et
bagdad annonce dans un communiqué que
les états unis poursuivraient le retrait
de leurs forces en irak
donald trump accueille le nouveau
premier ministre irakien à la maison
blanche pour évoquer ce départ et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans 10
minutes à 22 heures pile pour un point
complet sur l'actualité
on
[Musique]
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire france 3 c'est
ainsi que de polichinelle je ne crois
pas qu'il appartient à la france dé
l'eau des problèmes entre ivoiriens
le bénin ouattara et son régime sont en
train d'être brimée le preppy il faut
demander au régime ivoiris référence au
délai pas crisper davantage les
positions l'attention à toulouse vous
demander un report du scrutin prévu le
31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
là les circonstances pareilles c'est le
conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est comme on voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de soi
quels sont les facteurs qui vont nous
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un font 42
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar ce trop fine il
ya un tournant et on refermait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais une décision à vraisemblable
pour vous ça dépend quelle valeur on
attribuait la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
feu mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas le c'est un débat
moral un débat éthique
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tel
écho politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité mais idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient des
clients aujourd'hui on a une gauche
extrêmement tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre
l'enquète aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut
d'une voix nous devons maintenant
établir la chaîne de responsabilités
nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fuel donc ça pourrait aussi
actuellement se fracasser et causé un
deuxième déversement de pétrole plus ça
arrive après les collègues 19
nous avons secteur hôtelier et
touristique et un jeune ours blancs des
impacts de la catastrophe sur
l'environnement marin mais aussi sur les
populations niveau de la santé devront
se faire ressentir pendant des décennies
il faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on est de gauche
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande île de review
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dont des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui jugé amadou gon
coulibaly est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
nous estimons que l'opposant ouattara
est celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face aux plus fiction posent
à nous tant au niveau interne ou externe
climat particulier en ce moment en côte
d'ivoire et des violences sous prétexte
d'une manifestation et d'expression de
droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on est si m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas de raison que ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en pleine crise du coroner virus après
avoir constaté l'incapacité de l'union
européenne à manifester la moindre
solidarité envers des etam l'europe
une fois de plus est en crise la montée
en puissance de la chine dans le
commerce mondial a évidemment réduit le
poids de l'euro il faut y ajouter la
fragmentation de la zone et son
incapacité à parler d'une seule voix la
rend beaucoup moins attractif il est
évident que le projet politique d'une
véritable union est mort entre des
membres trop différent et romans la
vraie question est de savoir si le
président français va vouloir et pouvoir
rebondir et comment les choix sont
multiples mais tout le problème va être
bien choisi
[Musique]
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut être
catholique et féministe facilement il y
à un discrédit de principes posés sur le
mot féministe alors que c'est simplement
la reconnaissance de son existence
d'être féminin est ce que vous diriez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un an tu reçois
masculin dans l'église
bien sûr qu'il y à un entre soi mais ce
que la fim et un plafond de verre qui
empêche les femmes d'être pleinement
reconnus dans leur propre église
elles ne sont jamais autonomes dans leur
dans leur prise de décision
elles ne sont pas reconnues comme des
citoyennes à part entière
donc il est temps il est temps de dire
que l'église ne peut pas fonctionner sur
un seul de ses poumons
elle ne peut pas marcher sur une seule
de ses jambes
l'église doit être faite d'hommes et de
femmes et il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
la turquie au coeur du sommet euro med 7
qui se déroulent encore s'est réuni les
représentants de sept pays du sud de
l'europe
le président français appelle à faire
front commun face aux ambitions d'ankara
en méditerranée les européens doivent
selon lui
claire et ferme avec le gouvernement du
président r doan déclaration jugée
arrogante par nature qui de mettre cette
a par ailleurs évoqué d'éventuelles
sanctions de l'ue contre la turquie si
ankara de dialoguer pas septième jour du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015 des
cours d'assises spéciale du tribunal de
paris entend les proches des victimes de
la tuerie perpétrée dans la rédaction de
charlie hebdo
cinq ans après la tragédie la république
à sion des caricatures de charlie hebdo
où en est la liberté d'expression en
france
charlie tout ça pour ça c'était l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
donald trump au coeur d'une nouvelle
polémique le président américain aurait
volontairement minimisé
mines coronavirus c'est ce que révèle
une enquête menée par le journaliste
d'investigation bob woodward le
locataire de la maison blanche dit avoir
voulu éviter une panique ses adversaires
s'indigne à quelques semaines de la
présidentielle
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez les tensions en
méditerranée orientale au coeur du
sommet qui se déroule en corse ajaccio
accueilliez cet après midi cette
alliance informelle qui réunissait sept
pays méditerranéens membres de l'union
européenne
une rencontre présidée par emmanuel
macron cette rencontre s'est finalisé
avec l'accord de toutes les parties pour
des sanctions de l'ue contre la turquie
si ankara ne dialoguait pas et continuer
ses actions unilatérales de son côté
le président turc accuse le président
français de mettre en péril les intérêts
de l'europe écouter le président de la
république
le deuxième grand sujet que nous avons
abordé c'est évidemment celui de la
méditerranée orientale et de la relation
avec la turquie est au fond notre
objectif c'est véritablement de
restaurer des relations normales qui
permettent la stabilité dans la région -
avec la turquie d'obtenir la fin des
actions unilatérales de pouvoir obtenir
la fin des forages évidemment un plein
respect des de l'embargo sur les armes
pour l'ensemble des puissances de la
région en libye et d'accepter que sur
les désaccords qui existent dans la
région
la manière de les régler doit être
négocié et devant les enceintes
internationales
pour ce qui est des débats juridiques
qui sont les nôtres nous avons la
détermination de réengager ce dialogue
en coopération mais l'exigence aussi que
nos principes soient respectés dans la
durée je suis convaincu aussi que l'
échange entre l'union européenne et la
turquie est bénéfique pour les deux
parties il ya un agenda économique il ya
un agenda des changes énergétique qui
peut être retrouvé et c'est notre
souhait collectif exigences volonté d
escalade avec des principes simples et
claires que nous avons réaffirmé parce
qu aucun dialogue n'est possible s'il
repose sur un abandon de souveraineté ou
une faiblesse coupable répond claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales la turquie aurait
intérêt à se reprendre dans ses
velléités en méditerranée autrement la
grèce pourrait se tourner vers la cour
pénale internationale
le sua erdogan a toujours l'habitude de
tenir des propos excessifs
il a traité emmanuel macron et les
français de néocolonialistes parce
qu'ils étaient allés aider les libanais
ceci évidemment incomplètement est
complètement irréaliste à face à ça n'a
aucun sens et je pense qu'il reviendra à
la raison
d'ailleurs en turquie un certain nombre
d'éléments est compris dans l'armée
turque considère que
les propos et l'attitude du président
sont un peu aventuriste ce n'était pas
le meilleur moyen d'obtenir gain de
cause puisque le fond de la question
c'est qu'un jour il faudra bien
s'asseoir à la table avec les grecs pour
déterminer les limites des eaux
territoriales de la limite des vins et
des autres et puis comme l'a dit aussi
le premier ministre grec cet après midi
et bien si cette négociation échoue ou
si elle n'a pas lieu parce que monsieur
erdogan ne s'y prête pas et bien la
grèce se portera la faire devant la cour
de justice internationale de la haye et
la cour tranchera
il ya un droit de la mer il ya une
convention sur le droit de la mer par
conséquent les juges internationaux sont
parfaitement en état de trancher ce
différend
il est aussi question de politique
migratoire de l'union européenne après
l' incendie qui a dévasté le camp de
réfugiés de moria sur l'île de lesbos en
grèce le plus grand camp de réfugiés du
pays hébergées quelques près de 13000
demandeurs d'asile dont 4000 enfants
c'est 4 fois sa capacité d'accueil
la chancelière allemande confiance ce
soir une initiative de paris berlin 400
migrants mineurs non accompagnés seront
répartis entre les pays de l'ue eux qui
se rallieront à cette démarche et côté
angela merkel ait des grieux j'ai
demandé au premier ministre grec la
manière dont nous pourrions aider et sa
demande a été de prendre en particulier
les mineurs arrivée sur le continent
grecque
nous avons pris contact avec la france
l'allemagne et la france y participeront
j'espère que d'autres états membres de
l'ue le front tegan and english enfin à
noter que nous pouvons résoudre ce
problème quand semble donc dans un
premier temps ne commenceront par
l'offre faite à la grèce pour les
réfugiés mineurs et d'autres étapes
doivent suivre pour une responsabilité
commune
l'allemagne a accepté cette
responsabilité mais nous ne pouvons pas
nous contenter d'une politique
européenne en matière de migration au
fond cela n'existe pas aujourd'hui
et si cela continue ce sera un lourd
fardeau pour l'europe et c'est pourquoi
nous allons profiter de notre présidence
du conseil de l'ue eux pour faire des
progrès dans ce domaine
où en est la liberté d'expression en
france en plein procès des attentats du
7 janvier 2015 après la république à
sion des caricatures de charlie hebdo
les chiffres semblent plutôt alarmant
florian lambert le combat d'une vie
c'est en ces termes que l'équipe de
charlie hebdo évoque la liberté
d'expression cinq ans après la tuerie du
7 janvier 2015 qui a décimé la rédaction
du journal est choqué la france entière
charlie choisi de republier les
caricatures du prophète mahomet publiées
pour la première fois en 2006 est à
l'origine de la tacc djihadistes des
frères kwasi un choix courageux pour
certains provocateur pour d'autres cinq
ans après quel est l'état de la liberté
d'expression en france
le 2 septembre dernier charlie hebdo
publie une enquête de l'ifop sur l'état
de l'opinion en matière de liberté
d'expression de blasphème et de
caricature dans ce sondage
59% des sondés considèrent que le
journal a eu raison de publier ces
caricatures au nom de la liberté
d'expression
un chiffre en hausse de 21 points par
rapport à 2006 lors de la première
publication des dessins par charlie
hebdo
moi je pense qu'il faut pas se coucher
je crois que l'esprit de la france c'est
ce à quoi faut pas se coucher c'est vrai
que c'est une tragédie ce qui t'arrive à
charlie mais il faut passer dévoilant je
sais pas si ça ne doit jamais mourir en
fait faut pas oublier en fait on n'a pas
le droit
c'est important qu'ils tiennent cette
position après c'est courageux de leur
part quoi
j'aimerais bien d'autres éditeurs
puissent prendre le relais des partants
et republié republie chez continuer à
acheter
pas de problème pour les avocats et
proche de charlie hebdo l'art
publication des caricatures s'inscrit
dans le combat de la liberté
d'expression pour les futures
générations
ils se battent et continue à se battre
malgré les menaces malgré le fait qu'ils
n'ont plus de vie qui peuvent plus se
balader avec leurs femmes dans la rue
qui les vivent en résidence surveillée
qu'ils ont été obligés d'abandonner
leurs vies personnelles qu'ils vivent
dans un bunker
il continue à se battre ils ont ce
courage là de les republier il est re
publie pour les autres pour ces jeunes
générations là pour que puisse continuer
à vivre libres
même s'ils ne comprennent pas
l'importance de de la possibilité de
garder son esprit critique y compris à
l'égard des religions mais c'est plus
large que les religions c'est de toute
idéologie à la veille de l'ouverture du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015
emmanuel macron avait défendu depuis le
liban la liberté de blasphémer
je pense qu'un président de la
république en france n'a jamais a
qualifié le choix éditorial d'un
journaliste ou d'une rédaction jamais
parce que liberté de la presse à
laquelle vous tenez à juste titre
profondément il ya aussi en france une
liberté de blasphémer en france on peut
critiquer des gouvernants un président
blasphémer etc
l'enquète de l'ifop affirme néanmoins
que chez les moins de 25 ans 47% d'entre
eux ne sont pas en accord avec la ligne
éditoriale du journal
autre chiffre marquant 21 % des jeunes
français ne condamne pas explicitement
les auteurs des attentats
des chiffres éloquents qui n'ont pas
tardé à faire réagir l'ancien premier
ministre manuel valls qui se livrent à
une explication politique
quand je vois qu'il y à 20 % de jeunes
qui disent ne pas à condamner les
auteurs de ces attentats
le travail de fond et de pédagogie n'a
pas été suffisamment fait la liberté
d'expression a reculé parce qu'une
partie de la classe politique
une partie de la gauche a reculé d'après
un classement de reporters sans
frontières sur la liberté de la presse
la france se classe seulement en 34e
position en 2020 ces deux places de
perdues en un an pour le pays des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen et jean messia
membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national et il ya malamine
un militant associatif était sur rt
france pour en débattre je vous propose
d écouter on doit pouvoir tout dire moi
j'entendais dans votre reportage les
mots combat et se battre mais le combat
de la liberté d'expression il s'effectue
contre qui il s'est fait qu bien entendu
contre une sécession identitaire
islamistes en l'occurrence qui émane de
certaines immigrations qui entendent
appliquer en france une culture des lois
qui ne sont tout simplement pas les
nôtres la france est connue pour ses
pamphlets parfois très brute est très
violent du temps de louis xiv
c'est une véritable tradition de
caricatures tant qu'on ne s'attaque pas
à des individus mais qu'on s'attaque à
des messages religieux
et bien la loi permet de critiquer la
religion moi je ne dis pas que je
partage le point de vue de charlie
attention je suis quelqu'un de chrétiens
je comprends qu'on peut être choquées
par les caricatures de charlie un
journal qui prétend aujourd'hui être aux
avant postes avant et casser le cul
renata lui casser du musulman
c'est tellement plus confortable et
moins risqué en prétendant que soit dix
ans comme dit le général zawi est
d'ailleurs un bide total
on aurait une sorte de l'islamisme
politique amp en france alors qu'en
vérité les tic y ont tué à charrier
d'eau ne sont que de pauvres types perdu
deux cités qui se sont trouvés une cause
mais en aucun cas ils sont politisées
owen niveau intellectuel niveau
politisation ces trois vidéos sur
internet qu'ils ont radicalisé c'est un
peu léger
donc le fait de toujours attaquer des
faibles parce qu'on parle bien de fait
il n'y a pas d'organisation régionale
structurée en france y'a pas
d'international sa liste mais gérald
darmanin porte plainte contre jérôme
rodriguez mise l'intérieur réagit un
tweet publié hier par l'un des meneurs
n'est gilet jaune dans lequel il
comparaît des policiers bande de nazis
les détails avec robin pu elle jérôme
rodrigues ne mâche pas ses mots envers
les forces de l'ordre ce mercredi la
figure du mouvement des gilet jaune
publié un tweet incisif en réponse à un
message provocateur du syndicat de
police synergie officiers
il qualifie ses interlocuteurs de nazis
et compare les locaux de police un camp
de concentration
jérôme rodriguez fait référence à un
commissariat du xviiie arrondissement de
paris
utilisée lorsque la police procède à des
interpellations massives
un message qui ne passe pas auprès de
gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur a fait savoir
son intention de porter plainte
les propos de monsieur rodrigues envers
la police de la république sont ignobles
au nom du ministère et pour défendre
l'honneur de tous les policiers
je dépose plainte gérald darmanin
poursuit ainsi sa politique de tolérance
zéro contre les insultes envers les
policiers
le 26 juillet dernier le ministre de
l'intérieur avait annoncé porter plainte
contre le maire europe ecologie les
verts de colombes qui avait comparé les
forces de l'ordre qui traque les
migrants aux policiers et gendarmes qui
ont participé à la rafle
vel d'hiv des menaces de poursuites qui
ne surprennent pas jérôme rodrigues
quelque part c'est du corporatisme c'est
normal qu'ils défendent ces policiers
c'est dommage c'est normal qu'ils
défendent ces petites demoiselles
d'honneur qui était présente armés
jusqu'aux dents autour de son mariage
elle leur doit bien ça quand même hein
c'est normal donc dans l'absolu ça me
dérange pas plus qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire
me prendre ce que j'ai plus me prendre
plus qu ils m'ont enlevé aujourd'hui
dans ma vie amusez vous en même temps
vous êtes en train de gâcher l'argent du
contribuable pour des petites injures ce
que j'appelle les embrouilles de
sucettes et de vol de deux bonbons à la
récré je pense qu'il serait peut-être
plus intéressant de mettre dans l'argent
à améliorer aujourd'hui votre police est
de faire en sorte de virer tous ces
personnes qui mettent justement à mal
l'image de la police la tension
s'intensifie entre jérôme rodrigues et
les forces de l'ordre à quelques jours
de la reprise de la mobilisation des
gilet jaune en rassemblement est prévu à
paris le 12 septembre prochain
mais pour jean marie bigard mémorise les
propos de jérôme rodriguais sont
inacceptables et stigmatise toute la
police la police depuis beaucoup de moi
est entre le marteau et l'enclume et et
ils sont là et je connais beaucoup
défendre si tu veux les lois de la
république
alors taper dessus ça n'est pas possible
7 cette phrase qu'il a prononcée est
inouï elle est condamnable c'est à dire
on peut pas dire que les flics français
sont des nazis même si c'est vrai si ça
s'adresse à un seul wayne le flic c'est
comme si on condamnait la police
française si tu veux tout entière donc
je ne peux pas m'afficher avec quelqu'un
dont je ne partage pas les idées et
partout en france les gilet jaune sont
de retour à toulouse lyon lille nantes
et marseille entre autres plusieurs
appels à manifester ont été lancés en 12
septembre sous haute surveillance n'est
déjà des razak léger les jeunes vont-ils
réussir leur rentrée sur les réseaux
sociaux il semble en tout cas prêt à
redescendre dans les rues
puisque des appels à manifester ont été
lancés un peu partout en france
à paris quatre manifestations sont
prévues pour la première le rendez vous
est donné à 9 heures sur les champs
elysées est la deuxième ce sera 10
heures place de la bourse mais meurt
pour la troisième en revanche ça sera
place wagram la quatrième à 13 heures
place saint pierre et sur ces quatre
manifestations
trois sont d'ores et déjà interdite au
vu j'ai site des risques des troubles à
l'ordre public
le préfet de police a interdit les
rassemblements se revendiquant du
mouvement des gilet jaune à compter du
vendredi 11 septembre à 18 heures dans
plusieurs secteurs de la capitale ainsi
que deux manifestations ce samedi 12
septembre
parmi les secteurs concernés par ces
interdictions figurent notamment lé
champs elysées l'assemblée nationale
matignon la préfecture de police ou
encore le champ de mars
mais qu'importe l'interdiction certains
gilet jaune veulent un retour aux
sources et manifesté là où tout a
commencé sur les champs elysées
j'appelle à une désobéissance civile
complète
je vous invite ce jour là à ne montrer
aucune carte d'identité quitte à aller
faire un petit tour au commissariat pour
une vérité entités et qui passe à 80,30
perdre un oeil et les faire chier
appliquer la désobéissance civile
hashtag désobéissance civile
un appel à la désobéissance civile qui
est loin de faire l'unanimité et qui
suscite même la moquerie d'autres
leaders du mouvement où les avait
prévenus de votre évolution
elle est bien au chaud au s'asseoir il
campe tu t'en es ma team au commissariat
le fait d' exile fera demi tour avec le
sandwich on va te l'envoyer au comico
c'est pas grave qui reste quatre heures
et la révolution espace au commissariat
ouais
ces dissensions persistent depuis des
mois et elle ont peut-être même pesé
dans l'essoufflement du mouvement des
gilet jaune
quoi qu'il en soit tout l'enjeu de ce 12
septembre c'est d'évaluer si un nouveau
souffle est encore possible
l exécutif craint un retour de flamme et
pour cause la gestion du gouvernement de
la crise sanitaire a amplifié la colère
sociale
on dit qu'il ya la seconde vague du
coville et bien il va y avoir là la
seconde vague gilet jaune de hashtag de
septembre et ouais c'est une date très
importante ça va montrer le
mécontentement de la population
comme on peut le voir en ce moment c'est
délicat dans notre pays la rentrée sera
quand même très très très revendicatif
il ya des préoccupations qu'attendent
les français aujourd'hui c'est comment
vivre dignement et on avait toujours
demandé qu' un grenelle du poids d'achat
qu'ils soient faits en bois un grenelle
3 d'achat économiques et fiscales qui
sont organisées par l'état pour savoir
si aujourd'hui avec son salaire on peut
vivre dignement la démission des manuels
macron est toujours réclamé tout comme
les demandes pour plus de justice
sociale fiscales et environnementales
dans le détail les gilet jaune réclame
300 euros de plus pour les bas salaires
les retraites et les aides sociales
l'essence à 1 euro ou encore la
libération de plus de 800 manifestants
qualifié de prisonniers politiques
et c'est donc un week-end de tensions
qui se prépare avec la possibilité que
les antilles masse ce grève au mouvement
d'où notre question ce soir gilet jaune
policiers l'affrontement est il
inévitable mais là quand on parle
aujourd'hui gilet jaune et avec tout le
respect que l'on gaulois ou gilet jaune
on condamne bien évidemment ce qui est
le filtre ce mouvement de gilet jaune
pourra faire mouvement de violence
urbaine
donc bien sûr concret ce moment là mais
nous saurons paris nous serons préparés
pour empêcher de voir évoluer ces
violences urbaines comme enzo évolué
depuis
depuis quelques quelques années savez
notre organisation c'est au début le
mouvement des gilet jaune et gilet jaune
aujourd'hui n'existe pas comme mon il
existe
au tout début de simples bouts monsieur
jérôme rodriguez a peut être parlé sous
le coup de l'émotion parce que il s'est
senti attaqué sert personnellement
parlant et en mon nom je ne cautionne
pas ces propos je pense qu'il aurait
peut-être dû développer autrement
puisqu'il subit des attaques sur les
réseaux sociaux
en attendant faut pas oublier que
monsieur rodriguez est quand même un
éborgné sur 30 ont été et bornier
d'autres personnes ont été mutilés
n'oublions pas un de vos confrères
syndicaliste qui s'est ouvertement moqué
d'un jeune homme sébastien mallet qui a
perdu la main alors vous parlez
d'armement que vous utilisez ceci cela
ceci cela mais en attendant nous
n'essayons pas de détourner l'attention
désarmement que vous utilisez sondés
sont qualifiés d armement de guerre
cela a mutilé à épargner des personnes
sans compter des violences à outrance
des pacifistes ont été martyrisés la
situation sanitaire liée au corps un
virus en france avec les derniers
chiffres 9840 trois nouveaux cas de kobe
confirmé par un test le pays compte 350
de deux nouvelles hospitalisations liées
au virus en 24 heures il s'agit du total
de nouveaux cas le plus élevé depuis le
début des tests à grande échelle pour
violaine guérin médecins membres du
collectif laissons-les médecin prescrit
il faut que les thèses soit a prescrit
par les médecins avant de désengorger
les laboratoires il faut que la
population comprenne que elle doit
passer parfum est un généraliste qui
décidera à fait opportun ou pas de faire
les tests parce qu'aujourd'hui en plus
ça nous empêche complètement de
travailler sur le terrain puisque les
laboratoires font complètement en bolide
et moi j'ai passé ma semaine là à voir
des patients qui viennent pour des
pathologies compact lui faire leur
examen biologique
parce que il ya trois quatre heures de
queue sur sur les laboratoires donc
c'est très important
ne vous faites pas testé afin d'avoir un
avis médical n'a aucun sens de toute
façon de faire un test en étant
totalement asymptomatiques ou pour voir
si parce que de toute façon pour voir si
et bien 48 heures après on peut très
bien avoir à être en contact avec
quelqu'un donc il faut faire des tests
de façon avec des indications qui
nick tout à fait pertinente donc
aujourd'hui également sur le terrain les
médecins généralistes ou les médecins
spécialistes comme moi on ne voit pas de
cas graves de co vides la plupart des
personnes d'ailleurs n'ont même pas vu
de copie de patient malade depuis
plusieurs mois à deux mois de l'élection
présidentielle américaine donald trump
se retrouve à nouveau au coeur d'une
polémique dans un ouvrage un journaliste
l'accusent d'avoir volontairement
minimisé la gravité de la pandémie aux
états unis les précisions de quentin
mauclair un peu plus de 50 jours du
scrutin présidentiel la gestion de la
crise de donald trump refait surface à
l'origine des révélations du watergate
dans les années 1970 le journaliste bob
woodward écrit dans son nouveau livre
wrage que le président américain était
au courant de la dangerosité du virus
dès lé début de l'épidémie cela passe
par les airs c'est toujours plus dur que
le toucher tu n'as pas à toucher les
choses pas vrai mais l'air tu respires
juste l'air et c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et c'est donc une question très
délicate
c'est une question très délicate c'est
même plus mortel que votre grippe
fatigante
j'ai toujours voulu minimiser le danger
j'aime toujours le minimiser parce que
je ne veux pas semer la panique
c'est une chose horrible c'est
incroyable c'est si facilement
transmissible vous ne le croiriez même
pas le virus n'a rien à voir avec moi ce
n'est pas de ma faute c'est la chine qui
a laissé ce foutu virus se répandre
devant ces révélations la maison blanche
a tenu à réagir mercredi à l'occasion
d'une conférence de presse
ce président fait ce que font les
dirigeants les bons dirigeants à savoir
rester calme et résolue à un moment où
vous faites face à un défi insurmontable
c'est ce que ce président a fait donc à
l'écouté de ces enregistrements il
n'apparaîtra pas que le président a
menti au public américain le président
l'a jamais menti au public américain sur
locaux vides 19 le président a montré
qu'il était resté calme et ses actions
le reflète
habib semaines du scrutin présidentiel
joe biden ne séduit pas fait prier pour
enfoncer son rival dans cette nouvelle
polémique
il avait les informations il savait
combien c'était dangereux
et tandis que cette maladie morte
ravagé notre pays il n'a pas rempli sa
mission il s'agit d'une trahison du
peuple américain sur une question de vie
ou de mort une fois de plus de l'unc
trump est donc dans la tourmente
et alors que sa gestion de crise est
critiquée de part et d'autre l'actuelle
situation sanitaire ne plaide pas non
plus en sa faveur et plus de 190 1800
mort du co vite 19 les états unis
présentent en effet le bilan le plus
élevé au monde
et pour quel mot pas un correspondant
d'air téoz états unis donald trump fait
tout pour détourner l'attention sur
cette affaire l'idée qu'il essaierait
d'éviter une panique qu'il a essayé de
changer leurs discours pour se
concentrer sur le fait que gbagbo parte
a attendu avant de révéler ces
informations
de la trempe des seuils donc de
détourner la conversation et il dit
qu'il s'agit d'une tentative
d'influencer le résultat des élections
mais pour beaucoup d'américains ça ne
change rien et effectivement la gestion
de crise de donald trump semble être au
centre des préoccupations électorales
des américain donald trump est en retard
dans beaucoup de sondages et beaucoup
d'américains ont l'intention de voter
pour joe biden plutôt que donald trump
cependant ce n'est pas le vote populaire
qui détermine le président des états
unis mais les grands électeurs et il y
aura certes un état clé pour déterminer
le président et certains de ces états
clés sont encore des bastions du
président des états comme loyaux le
michigan luis comme si nous la
pennsylvanie et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité demain
matin 7 heures du matin heure de paris
[Musique]
un bon sapeur c'est quelqu'un de très
apprécié mais je vous dirais déjà à
paris ça pour être sûr qu aujourd'hui
pouvait faire tous les kilomètres vous
devrez pas quelqu'un en automne on en
plein mois de novembre à bien comme ça
j'aime tous mes sauf l'anonymat
l'anonyme avait surmonté cette fois tu
viens de chez toi tu vas au boulot tu
reviens parce que tu as dit monsieur
madame vous êtes et les gaulois la vie
est belle en couleurs pourquoi diable
bleu vous pour vous arrêter au noir bleu
marine j'ai dit non